finding your passion is one of the most
important and least understood things
that I think you can do especially as an
entrepreneur we've all heard the
expression find your passion find your
passion you got to do what you love and
from all the videos that I've done and
all the people that I've studied and
profile whether they're entrepreneurs
innovators athletes recording artists
like whatever they are the number one
rule that they all have in common is
find your passion when I get asked
you've studied all these people what's
the most common thread that's it find
your passion you have to be doing the
work that you love but how do you do it
how do you find it because most of the
time we know what we don't want you know
the life that you don't want you know
the people who you don't want to be
hanging around you've been at some job
that you do not enjoy we typically know
what we don't want but we haven't done
the work or been given the tools to know
what we do want and that's what I'm
going to cover in this video for me I
love helping entrepreneurs I think your
purpose comes from your pain right so
whatever you struggle the most in life
is what you want to help other people
through you are built to serve so your
purpose your passion becomes a part of
that will definitely be in service to
other people somehow it's not enough for
it just to be about you and so your
purpose comes through your pain your
purpose is to help other people through
something especially what you went
through Yourself fashion component
though is actually enjoying the work to
get people to the other side so for me I
love helping entrepreneurs I struggled a
lot in my early days as an entrepreneur
I'm basically trying to make the world
of 19 year old Evans who are struggling
not struggle as much as I did and so I'm
trying to share whatever wisdom I have
share the lessons from other successful
entrepreneurs so that all of the 19 year
old Evans out there can learn and can
improve and get better new motivation
watch top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Nina Carmichael and we make these
videos because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of much more and you
get that Push by surrounding yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and our take on his top 10
rules for Success enjoy
I have a process that I call the passion
process and if you go through this
process it will help you identify your
passion
and give you a lot more light love
energy and money you know because we got
to make money as entrepreneurs so the
passion process is this if you want to
go through it make a list of all the
things that you've done to help other
people
especially the kind of people who who
are who you used to be like make a list
and I went through this process and
built a serve I did this with my wife to
help her find her passions this is where
it was birthed
but if you just make a list of all the
things that you enjoyed helping people
with like you you got them a result
you're so happy that they are now in a
different spot because of what you did
like what did you do where you showed up
and you helped somebody with something
and just if you want to pause the video
you can if you want to make a mental
list just all the things that you've
done to help other people okay
after you have that list
then write down or just circle the ones
that you actually enjoyed the process of
doing as opposed to just the end result
this is where we get stuck this is where
entrepreneurs get trapped okay we enjoy
the end result of what we've done but we
don't enjoy the process of doing it how
many times have you helped somebody else
out because you're a good person because
you're built to serve because you love
that person or even you see yourself in
that person and you just wanna you just
want to help
and you're so happy that you helped them
but you didn't actually enjoy the work
that you were doing and that's the key
difference the result has to be there
that you help somebody of course and the
thing that will make you light up come
alive love doing for the rest of your
life is the actual work you're doing you
love to so to bring it home that's some
great Theory awesome
in my example
the example that I use in in built to
serve in my book is I love helping
entrepreneurs like I want to see you win
I every day I wake up and I try to
figure out what else can I do to try to
help entrepreneurs win how else can I
help the 19 year old Evans of the world
out there get their business off the
ground
and if you were to move your office say
you're going from a home office to you
got your first office it's like wow you
got your first place amazing and you
needed help moving I could help you move
and I would be so happy to see you in
your new office
the problem is
I don't enjoy the process of moving I
don't want to unplug computers and pack
them in boxes and move desks and sure it
might be a fun workout but I I don't get
lost in the process of that right I
don't love it I love the end result of
helping the entrepreneur but I don't
love the process of getting the
entrepreneur to that result and that's
the key difference that's where most of
you will get trapped you love the end
result and feel like what you're doing
matters and is important great and you
get that little hit at the end like yes
I helped that person but did you
actually enjoy the process of you doing
the work and if not that's what we need
to revisit most entrepreneurs are doing
too much of the work that they do not
enjoy just trying to get to the result
now not everything you do is going to be
amazing not everything that you do is
gonna is gonna fill you up with joy and
passion a lot of running the business
does suck and you have to do things you
know accounting and taxes and legal
stuff it's not stuff that makes me come
alive when I find joyous but your goal
as an entrepreneur needs to be to spend
more time in that zone of Genius where
you do actually love it and at the
beginning you know maybe it's 50 50 but
hopefully as you build and scale and
grow and learn more about yourself you
can shift the percentage of how much you
do that is in your zone of Genius that
you love doing versus what has to get
done to grow the business right and as
you build and scale and grow that's
hopefully where team comes into place to
handle all those things that have to get
done that you don't enjoy doing so if
you make your list of all the ways that
you have helped people if you have no
idea what's my passion you have no idea
make a list of all the things that you
have done that you've you've enjoyed the
result of helping somebody what have you
done to help people then Circle the ones
where you actually enjoyed the process
so I don't want to help entrepreneurs
move and pack boxes even if it leads to
a great result I want to do something
that I enjoy doing Rule Number Two start
standing up
for myself and standing up for what I
might believe in and the the
standing up what is it it's not
metaphysical the the the theoretical I
don't know but but actually standing up
like the physical standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
setting up was probably
wow I don't know maybe maybe 20 years
ago 15 years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline be underneath it and I get 20
to 40 000 jumps a day on my trampoline
and went through three trampolines last
year because they broke because most are
not designed to be jumped on that often
but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found that when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients I
would be better when I was walking
around I don't know if it's a nervous
energy or what but when I sat down it
was
less energetic less less like let's go
do this thing and when I when I stood up
it was just I had more energy
you test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
fidget with my ring so my ring whenever
I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking I like walking around just
having something go and it helps me
think and process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss
again way back in the day and the the
test was not a full-on stand-up desk
because those barely existed but I took
my bookcase
and I cleared off the book all the books
in the bookcase and I found the shelf
that was the kind of the best height to
put my laptop on and I just tried
standing there and I think this is a
good life hack not just for standing up
or not but just in general if you want
to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand-up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for it to
be delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
is just start find a small way to just
get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase
and the first day I didn't last very
long 20 minutes 40 minutes I it didn't
last very long when you're not used to
standing up it it's really hard it's
like oh where I need to sit down and
after that first 20 or 40 minutes I got
tired and I had to sit down because my
body wasn't used to it but while I was
standing up it's like I really like this
this is cool I have more energy in just
answering emails and whatever else I was
doing at the time I had more energy so
I'm gonna try it again and that 20
minutes became 30 minutes between 40
became two hours became four hours
became six hours to the point was like I
could just stand up all day long it
became weird when people came over to my
office because there were no chairs to
sit down at so when we're doing a
meeting I'm standing up and so they were
standing up because there were no chairs
and it felt awkward to have one person
standing one person sitting and then
they start getting tired because after
20 minutes of standing up we got tired
so I had to I had to bring chairs back
to my office to host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had foot issues I
had uh things that you put in your in
your shoes what they're called not
implants uh customized Souls whatever I
was going to a car like in my 20s I was
going to chiropractor almost every week
because my back was was a mess my knees
were were achy and cracking every time I
was walking like my body seemed to be
falling apart in my 20s I'm now 42 in
May I'm 42 and my body is in better
condition than I was in my 20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier
the move to a trampoline came because I
was I was already standing up for at
least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh
backstage he would always jump before he
goes on stage Tony jumps a couple times
on his rebounder rebounder is just a
mini trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what'd you have in your
backyard a rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go and so that's pretty
cool I wonder what he's spraying in his
mouth uh and I like the whole trampoline
thing if I'm already standing up why not
get a trampoline and try and so again
what's what's the easiest way to go off
and do it well I I went to my local
Walmart and I bought a rebounder and
brought it home and
had to adjust the height of my desk and
had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right but
whatever it's fine Lessons Learned right
you figure it out you think do is this
worth doing or not
take the idea that you've got and try
because again the biggest thing that
most people are missing is just momentum
you're just not trying you have this
you've got this idea and we spend our
best energy planning it and ideating and
researching and what's the perfect
trampoline and what's the perfect
stand-up desk and you spend all that
energy researching and then tomorrow you
wake up the next week you come back or
the next month or whatever like nothing
has happened on it still
leave all these great intentions but
there's not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them
and so go get the stand-up desk by
creating boxes in your office
you know go get the cheapest trampoline
at Walmart and just jump on it and see
how it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore uh
we actually moved we just sold our place
we bought a new place and I moved uh
into one of the rooms as a temporary
place while we were showing our place
because my office backdrop doesn't is
not very conducive to selling the house
most people are not used to a stand-up
desk a giant stand-up desk and
trampoline and all that and so I took my
office down because when you're selling
a home you wanted to appeal to everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say
sitting is the new smoking right so try
standing up and just give it a shot and
don't stress out if you get tired after
20 minutes like I did the first time
through it's okay but do you have more
energy while you're working while you're
standing up and if so then just keep
going and just start with the bookshelf
for some bookshelves uh or some boxes
whatever just to get started and the
second lesson is is just do something
just momentum imperfect action the ideas
that you have in your head are great
they're genius you need to do something
you need to stop putting the gas pedal
on the energy that's flowing through you
like greatness is flowing through you
and you're actively saying stop stop
stop do something find the smallest
possible way today today like right now
the smallest possible way to take that
awesome idea in your head and build some
momentum towards it because the only
thing you're missing towards your great
life is the momentum rule number three
alter your behavior I think we play
small by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we have it
trained in US
from a young age our parents our family
our friends our teachers think about who
did you learn about life from probably
people who didn't like their own life
you know who did you learn about careers
from probably people who did not have a
great career you know who barely are
enjoying what they're doing in their
work and they're living in scarcity
mindset of this is all I can do and
that's what we've learned from and you
know guidance counselors at school do
they love what they're doing I mean I
think this is a huge problem and we're
stuck living small and living scared and
living as a result way below our
potential of what we could do and who we
could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problem it's what I wake up every day
trying to do trying to help trying to
create and so how do you how do you get
out of it well I think the starting
point is being around the people who are
living and doing the things that you
want to do I think the way to 10x your
results is not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially at the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you
get to a point where you can't actually
10x your work anymore it's changing your
mindset it's getting new leverages
busting through limiting beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wins without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
never accomplish their goals who don't
end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both and so
if you're not working hard then you
don't have a shot but assuming you are
working hard and you want a 10x again
then it's a shift in mindset and the
shift in living beliefs so how do you
identify the living beliefs how do you
figure out where it's holding your back
how do you break through the Paradigm
and hit a new level a lot of it is
environmental
the current thinking that you have was
environmental it's your parents and your
family and your guidance counselor and
teachers and family Etc that's
environmental you've adopted their
beliefs in unfortunately a lot of them
are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever's more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people every day but
you know we can't so how do you do it
well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
I think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter and when somebody
asked me yesterday on Instagram do I
think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
I said no I don't think you'll buy
Twitter but it's probably not a good
idea to underestimate Elon Musk
just in general right you know lots of
people have underestimated him and he's
proven them wrong many many many times
and I just like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically if
you're thinking through it if you're if
you were running Tesla uh in SpaceX
would you have thought about buying
Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at this hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if he
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expensive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors what I call them in Elon Musk a
John Assaraf at Oprah Winfrey people who
who you may never meet but you can still
learn a heck of a lot from
step two was to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but what are some
changes you can make to your environment
what are some conferences or events you
can go to to be around the people who
think the way that you want to think to
inject some newness some creativity some
ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you are in that things that used to
make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
conference an event you come back I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just just think about if
you're just constantly stuck it doesn't
mean you have to go travel on vacation
it may mean you take up salsa dancing it
may mean you try a new hobby take that
idea that you've got and just go go to
it look at any events that are happening
in your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use uh
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class at you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at
but he wouldn't have known that unless
he dropped out of school and dropped in
on the calligraphy class so it's
changing the environments being a part
of new things it's it's not just staying
stuck in the same habit the same
routines and and same thing you're doing
constantly and that will inject newness
that will then allow you to be more
creative and create amazing
opportunities for your next goals so
step one is to be around aspirational
mentors to be around the people like an
Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey Etc watching
videos content interviews podcasts books
that make you feel better stronger more
courageous step two is to get out of
your comfort zone and go go to things
physical things travel more take take on
classes say yes go to conferences and
events just so that you expose yourself
to new ideas and opportunities and come
up with fresher ideas of what you could
do with your life and step three is to
to actually have humans in your life who
you're around who make you want to push
and do more and be better and this mean
hey if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know some Movie Maker is
something else but being around other
people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really really struggled so find
other people who are on this journey
that you can do it with because when you
feel like you're doing it with other
people and you're not alone you'll be a
lot more productive a lot more effective
and have a lot more fun as well rule
number four I stop thinking small
honestly I think we're all thinking
small
you're thinking small I'm thinking small
we're all thinking small compared to
what what we're capable of and I think
we've been conditioned to think small
we've been conditioned by our upbringing
our family our our parents our guidance
counselors our teachers our
we've just been conditioned to think
small because we're learning about life
from people who
also never thought big and so
because we are products of our
environment we have conditioned
ourselves to think the same way as if
the people in our environment and if
you're not happy with your environment
and your environment is not around
around big people who've done amazing
things or thinking big then you will
stay stock thinking small as well what I
love about Naveen Jane is that he thinks
big you know the first time I found this
content there were three people who
I get recommended all the time you
should do a top 10 on this person you
should do an Express on this person you
should profile this person and there
were three people who for the first time
upon first consumption of their content
really blew me away one was Denzel
Washington
uh if you have not seen Denzel
Washington you should go watch his top
ten he his backup plan for his life was
being a minister uh and he is a fire
presenter I just kind of a lot of times
we do actors it's really hard to get
anything good out of the interviews that
they're doing uh but Denzel Washington's
a whole other animal so he really blew
me away the second was Priyanka Chopra
uh who had just amazing set of
interviews and super intelligent bright
woman and the third was Naveen Jane
where I'd like no idea who this person
is you should do Naveen Jane great go
look him I was like oh my gosh this
guy's amazing I want more Naveen Jane in
my life I think that's a great sign you
know like when you find people like that
even if you've never met them and up
until this year I had never met Naveen
Jane I had the Good Fortune I just
recently have him on on my channel to do
an interview in a collaboration but up
until that point I'd never met him
before and
when you find the people who make you
think bigger who make you feel more
confident to make you feel more bold
be around them more
this is my solution right I am trying to
hang out even if it's just virtually
with the people who inspire me to want
to play a bigger game you know either
those three people I haven't met Denzel
Washington
yet I haven't met Priyanka Chopra yet uh
and up until you know this year I hadn't
met Naveen Jane yet but I can still be
inspired by them I can still learn from
them I can still look at their content
and they can still push me to become
better
and I think
a lot of us stay stuck and stay small
because it's so
good to feel important
and we end up being the big fish in a
small pond if you're watching this video
you are probably the one that's pouring
into
everybody else you're probably the most
optimistic person in your circle you're
probably the one who cares the most
about the people around you you're
probably doing the most for the people
in your circle and you're the one people
come to and say Hey how do I X you know
how do I grow how do I get better how do
I you're the one that's advising and
helping and pushing other people maybe
pushing them too much
that makes sense maybe you're maybe
you're pushing some people too much but
you're the most optimistic most
ambitious person in your circle probably
that's great in a sense and that you can
pour and give back and help others along
the way but who's pushing you
you know if you don't have somebody
pushing you to be better to be stronger
to be greater to be more ambitious to
think bigger than you probably won't
like if you it's really uncomfortable to
think bigger
and if you don't have somebody inspiring
you pushing you helping you then you
probably stay stuck and that's what we
need to change and so it's a message for
you but it's a message for me equally so
and so step one in doing that I think is
just changing the environment to be
around the people who do inspire you and
chances are most of the people who do
inspire you are not not people who have
you have direct access to and not people
who are taking on an intern you know
Warren Buffett's not taking on an intern
to go live with him for a year as far as
I know
so how do you do it well the easy way is
through content
I've learned so much and been inspired
so much by just amazing people through
the content on my own channel like I
make these videos for me because I need
them because I need to believe more in
myself and then I share that with you
and thankfully enough of you like it
that I can make it a business and hire a
team and continue to make even more
content because if it was just me then
it'd be a lot fewer videos coming up and
a lot less profiles and a lot less
content
so being around the people and when you
find people who really speak to you who
really get you going who's like yes this
is exactly what I need then
be around them more subscribe to their
channels buy their books listen to their
podcast be around them more if they're
speaking an event go to the event
because it'll push you to reach another
level and this is why it's so great to
have so many people now I'm I'm
passionate about helping bring
new people onto the to platforms like
YouTube and getting their message out
there because some people
[Music]
will push you through things some people
will hug you through things everybody
has their own lens and you'll connect
with people in a different way so you
look at a Eric Thomas so you look at a
Jocko willink or you look at uh Andy
frisella
who are going to be very in your face
cut right to the truth no BS no excuses
no wiggle room like get up and go chase
down your life you know it's a hard push
they may be yelling at you they're very
intense it's a hard push forward and
there'll be other people like Oprah like
um brene Brown like Dave Meltzer who
have a different approach it's a much
softer approach they'll hug you through
it you know some people will push you
and yell at you to get through and some
people will hug you through it a lot of
times the message is exactly the same
you know Oprah's message is very similar
to Eric Thomas's message the difference
is the delivery
Oprah will hug you through it and Eric
will push you through it and it really
just depends on what you need there's no
right or wrong it's just what do you
need and when you find the people who
give you what you need just be around it
more be around that more because no
matter how much you watch
one video
the impact will wear off right like
you're waking up tomorrow
the same person you were almost
yesterday maybe a half a percent better
but you could be you could watch this
video get all inspired be like yes all
right I'm gonna chase things down
amazing let's go and you have energy for
a few hours for the day but then you
wake up tomorrow and and that energy is
gone right has that happened to you that
energy suddenly is not there anymore you
don't feel as bold as courageous or
ambitious as you were yesterday why what
happened
it's not that there's nothing wrong with
you it's just normal
because you got an injection into your
environment that took you to another
level and then it it fell off
because there was no consistency in the
environment so you are where you
consistently do so whatever you want to
accomplish whoever you want to be to
consistently surround yourself with
people like that
because you're not getting enough in
your home environment your home your
environment now your life has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are it's allowed you to get to where you
are right now amazing and if that's
where all you want to be awesome
congratulations you've done it you've
you've hit the jackpot but if you want
more
then your current environment is not
designed to help you go and get more and
again I'm talking to myself just as much
as I'm talking to you but like saying
these words out loud it's like what
changes do I need to make to my
environment who do I need to be hanging
out with more either in person or just
through the video content to make me
want to push more be more courageous
save save
Bolder things and have bigger
aspirations and goals and dreams and and
take Boulder action towards
accomplishing them
right makes a big big difference and so
if you want to accomplish something if
it's business success or mindset success
then you know if it's just thinking
bigger then if you love Naveen Jane be
around Naveen Jane more
watch all those interviews and then
listen to any podcasts that he does and
I did one on my main Channel we'll link
that up at the end of this video you can
go watch if you want if you want to
improve your health and fitness and
you're tired of you know being on an
Oreo diet okay
you can make a choice and decision that
I'm gonna I want to be this person I
want to be the person who works out I
want to be the person who takes care of
my body takes care of my health and
energy and
that's awesome as a decision but you
need the environment to support you and
so now if you're subscribing to health
channels if you're following people on
Instagram who are working out and take
care of their bodies it will make you
want to live a healthier life one of the
ones that I love watching is Tom bilyu
and his health Theory show where he's
interviewing experts around health and
every time I listen I was listening to
one this morning every time I listen
watch it makes me want to be a little
bit healthier
you know the more that you're around
that kind of stuff the more you will
take on the mindset similarly if you're
injecting poison like if you're around
negative people or you're consuming
negative content and that's most of the
news and most of media to be honest is
mostly negative if you're surrounded by
negativity constantly and you're you're
watching negative videos and reading
negative news constantly you will be a
lot more negative you'll be a lot more
scared you'll be a lot more scarcity
mindset you'll be a lot more afraid
you'll be a lot less positive and
ambitious because that's what you're
feeding into your mind so be very
careful about now designing and
Engineering your environment your
environment has happened to you
you know you've had some control over it
but it's it's mostly happened to you
and now you can with intent change it
to be more positive if you had to ask
yourself if I wanted to surround myself
with the most positive encouraging
inspiring
people who will make me more courageous
bold and ambitious
who would those people be what would
that environment look like
and then make a choice
change it
change who you subscribe to change what
you're listening and watching
unsubscribe from all the channels that
make you feel worse about yourself
change your physical environment what
what clothes are you wearing what do you
put on the wall around you what's your
background on your cell phone and on
your computer you start to change it and
when you change your environment it'll
Force the change in your habits in your
mindset and in your
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five don't be afraid
of failure you're not afraid of failing
you're afraid of failing in front of
other people you will sing in the shower
but you won't sing on the street corner
why because of other people because they
may see you because they may laugh at
you because they may say look at that
person they're so dumb right you're not
afraid of failing not not just by
yourself you're afraid of failing and
who is going to watch and so that
becomes really important because it now
means you're living your life based off
of other people's expectations and
judgments and maybe that's
people in your own family maybe that's
people you know maybe that's your mom or
maybe that's random people you're afraid
of the Judgment of unknown YouTube
commenters and leaving some kind of
feedback on your video telling you how
much you suck right we're afraid of the
people that we care deeply about in
their perspective and opinions on us and
we're also afraid of the the people who
we don't know yet who are just out there
in the world on the internet who might
come and leave negativity on whatever
you're going to be creating so you're
not actually afraid of failing you'll do
it all the time but it's failing and who
is going to see us fail and so
there's a lot to unpack inside of that
let's start with
what is your big goal what do you want
to accomplish what mission are you on
who are you trying to serve who are you
trying to help and in order for you to
go off and accomplish those things and
serve to your highest capability you're
going to have to do things that will be
scary where you're going to risk failure
right if you are never risking any kind
of failure then you're living your life
so small and so safe that you don't like
your life
if there's nothing in your calendar in
the next month that you are excited by
the that your heart's getting you're
you're scared right you're nervous right
you're like oh my gosh that thing's
happening if there's nothing in your
calendar that's like that you don't like
your life that that's honestly most
people
you're just photocopying your same life
over and over and over and over and over
again that's what most people wake up
and do I'm sitting here in the Costco
parking lot right like most most people
you just wake up and you're photocopying
the same day you had yesterday and last
week and last year and that's not a life
so you have to be willing to risk some
kind of failure which would potentially
risk other how other people see you and
judge you I used to not be able to
record videos like this I mean the first
video I ever recorded in public
was I was walking down the street at my
old house
and I was challenged by my agent he said
you have to record videos in public like
Steve like fetus in public are you crazy
I can barely make videos at home I'm
going to now make them in public like
you have to do it like okay great so I'm
walking down the street carrying my big
video camera at the time and
I made sure I picked a really quiet
section of the street where nobody was
usually outside because it made me feel
like I was recording the video and doing
the task but there was nobody around so
I wasn't really doing the task and I
remember there was a male male uh male
woman who was dropping off mail and
soon as I saw her and I felt like I was
in auditory range of her then I pulled
the camera down
and then as I passed her I started
filming again
it's like I did the assignment Steve
look I filmed outside
why because I'm afraid of of a male
woman's opinion of me like she doesn't
even care about me she's she's living
her life doing her thing
and so something like this now I'm
sitting here in a parking lot filming
and people are walking by and some
people are watching like what's this guy
doing you keep going you just keep
making because fear of other people's
judgments cannot be a good enough reason
for you to play small not anymore and if
you want to do great things most of the
people judging you don't like their own
lives and any judgment they have of you
is just a reflection of self
so there's a couple of hacks that I've
used to be able to get through it that
might serve you number one is studying
successful people and anytime you study
successful people you find out that they
failed along the way to their success
a lot of times you may just see on the
surface just their accomplishments and
list of what they've done and all that
and it could feel
um imposing you know how are they so
perfect and I suck and I have all these
fears and insecurities but if you look
deeper into their story and maybe watch
some of their interviews or videos
you'll see that they struggled a lot and
they had multiple failures on their path
to success and I used to before my
channel came out I used to read
stories of different famous
entrepreneurs and how they got started
and you know the kind of zero to one
story because it made me feel like
it was possible
that looking at Warren Buffett now is
crazy you know it's like he's done so
much you can't relate but how do you go
from zero to one and what did he
struggle with and where did he fail that
was inspiring to say hey okay if he
could get through that
now me decades later with a lot more
opportunity and technology and resources
and I could do that
you know I could do something similar so
that inspired me to to get out of my
cocoon and to be around people who are
doing amazing things inspired me to want
to go off and do more it's also why I
make videos like this so that you can
learn from Warren Buffett and all the
people that we profile and because I
think the more that you're around that
the more you'll win I don't know Warren
Buffett personally you probably don't
maybe you do maybe you can text him and
ask for advice I can't not yet but I can
watch his videos and I can learn from
him and I can get better and I can
improve Myself by being around him and
the more that I watch his videos the
more I can think like him just a little
bit and and that's important because
that shifts you forward so being around
more successful people will shift you
towards success even if they are virtual
through through a computer screen
through videos podcasts books Etc
the second thing is
teaching myself that I do difficult
things
and I think that's really important
because we've accepted fear as a good
enough reason for you not to do the
thing you've accepted other people's
opinions as a good enough reason for you
not to do the thing my trigger words I
call them play bigger triggers you come
up with the triggers that will allow you
to play bigger so if I say scary
difficult or hard then I go off and do
it because I want to be the person who
does the things that are scary difficult
or hard to myself and that's why I still
make videos that's why I write books and
speak on stage and find all of those
things incredibly scary difficult and
hard
so what is it for you and when you can
stop accepting scary difficult or hard
as a good enough reason like I want to
do it but I'm scared okay well that's
not good enough reason you've already
set you've pre-decided that that's not a
good enough reason so you have to go up
and do the thing it's a scary difficult
heart and you say it you write it you
think it you tell somebody else it as
long as that is the reason for you to
put the brakes on your life it's not a
good enough reason anymore it has to be
something stronger than scary difficult
or hard otherwise you have to go and
take action and you start to teach
yourself that you are the kind of person
who takes on things that are scary
difficult to hard so number one was
being around successful people
study them and learn from them and get
mentorship from them even if it's just
through a video number two is that you
do difficult things and then number
three is
focus on service
and
if you understand that the thing that
you're afraid to do
is not just for you it's for other
people right if you're an entrepreneur
you're trying to create a business it's
not just for you this sure there's
selfish goals of I want to I want to
make money and provide for my family and
live a great life Etc but above that
needs to be service and helping others
that you're creating something that's
going to bring value to other people
that it's not just about you making
money but you're providing a real
service something really valuable to
other people that's going to make their
life better if I'm making videos it's
not just about me and numbers on the
channel it's about it's about you and
hopefully for for one of you watching
this video it has a big impact today
when I speak on Sage or read the books
it's not about me it's about who I can
help serve and whenever you can deeply
connect to who you can help serve
at least for me it gives me the courage
to go off and do the thing if I'm
terrified to speak on stage
I'll often look behind the curtain at
the audience and I'll try to find a
couple people it's like I'm doing it for
that person I'm doing it for him I'm
doing for her I've got a message that I
can share that can help them and that
gives me the confidence and the courage
to go do the thing because we'll show up
for other people more than we'll show up
for ourselves and so when you can tie
what you're doing to other people to
Value to service to helping them it'll
give you more confidence and courage to
go off and do the thing that you need to
do and so I call that the push and the
hug so
the I do difficult things I do scary
things is the push like get out get out
there and do this Carmichael let's go
and the service is the hug like hey I'm
not I'm not doing this just for me I'm
doing it for for all the people out
there as well and some days you need
more of the hug some days you need more
of the push
and you just lean in on what you feel
you need most you know there are some
days when pushing yourself harder is not
the answer you need a hug and there are
some days where hugging yourself more is
not the answer you need to push
and so having a self-awareness and now
okay I need the push right now or I need
the hug right now and then going off and
doing that will give you the momentum
that you need
failure
failure is gonna happen
and the biggest failure again is that
the fear of other people seeing you fail
and as long as you live your life by the
expectations of other people you will
live small forever and if you can flip
it to say I'm doing this to help others
I'm doing this because
I want to live a great life and I'm
doing this because I do difficult things
when you can make that shift happen you
start to accomplish your goals rule
number six build connection with people
as an introvert Making Connections
always seemed incredibly scary to me I
hate going to networking events I'm not
the life of a party I don't know how to
approach people and ask them questions
and it always just felt I think at the
end of the day very fake and inauthentic
and just not me you know I don't know
how to introduce myself and I don't know
I don't know what to talk about I want
to sit here and talk I'm here in Arizona
and it's beautiful and it's sunny and
it's amazing but I don't I don't I don't
want to just talk about the weather you
know I don't want to talk about
boring
superficial stuff and
it took me a long time to get
comfortable coming to events and I'm
this is actually a great moment because
I'm here at genius Network
um it's a I just came out of a two-day
event where people are paying 25 000 to
be a part of and the next two days uh
it's another event where they're paying
a hundred thousand miles to be part of
and I'm a guest here speaking at um at
both events and I would have I would
have never like younger Evan would have
never come to something like this
because
not that it's not valuable just I would
have been too afraid to to network and
to uh to ask for help and to introduce
myself and all of those things what I've
discovered if you're an introvert
what I've discovered is that introverts
are great listeners
and we care
and you can be a fantastic networker if
you're an introvert but your goal is not
to know the entire room and the goal is
not to run into the the event and say
look at me here's what I do and where
the shiniest suit and be be the
loudmouth if that's you awesome roll
with it but if it's not your goal is to
just connect with a few people on a
really meaningful level
I've connected over the past couple days
with some amazing people who've given me
some amazing advice and connections and
experiences and
just amazing people but it hasn't been I
don't there's lots of people who I
haven't connected with
you know there were maybe
50 people here over the past two days
and in the bigger the more expensive
group I think there's 30 people or 20
people coming and I probably won't get
to talk to everybody
um probably not I mean maybe
but I'm not I'm not I I'm not judging
myself for not knowing everybody I'm not
judging myself for
how many business cards I leave with
though I don't do people you still use
business cards I don't have any business
cards I'm not judging myself by if I
connected with them or not it's more I'd
rather spend
time with a few people
who I can connect with on some kind of
level and
that ends up leaving to so much better
things Joe polich is the guy who runs
this so this is his office and he's the
one put puts his events together and
he's he's known as the most connected
man in the world right some of his bios
and websites will say people talk about
him he's the most connected man in the
world in hanging around him for the past
few days I can understand why so if
we're going to reverse engineer
Joe polish's success and he'll he'll say
that he's you know on the introverted
side
um
he's invited me to his home
he's I came in a couple days early and
helped him with his team and His Channel
and he invited me to stay at his home
today's our day off in between the two
events and he's invited me to go work
out with him and go do some IVs with
vitamins in it and go sit in a hot sauna
then jump in a nice cold bath and ask me
how I'm doing and what I'm up to and if
I need if I need anything or if I want
to use his office I mean I'm using I'm
using his office I guess the outside the
film today it's too beautiful today not
to film outside but but whatever I need
he doesn't just do that for anybody you
know he's not just going to open up his
home for anybody
and he's really trying to spend time
think about me if I would do that and I
think man probably not and so that's
that's maybe a learning for me because
I've run events I've hosted my own
events and they usually just knock me
out when I when I've hosted my thought
Leadership Academy in Toronto it would
knock me out I mean the last day of one
of the um
the last day of my event I remember I I
passed out like I had a break of 15
minutes and I I passed out and fell
asleep on a floor like on my dance floor
because I was giving so much and then my
my body gave out on me
and so I couldn't imagine then also like
Joe's got such a crazy week think about
how much people are paying him right
they pay him twenty five thousand
dollars for
the event that just finished and then a
hundred thousand dollars for the event
that's coming up
you gotta deliver some value right if
people are coming and they're paying a
hundred thousand dollars to be here that
that's
got to be at least for me incredibly
stressful to do that and while he's in
the middle of all of that he's worried
about me and how I'm doing and if I want
to stay with him and if I need to if I
want to go do some vitamin IVs and if
I'm being looked after if I need an
internet connection or a place to work
and the amount of text that he sent
while he's
in the sauna or working out or
doing his meetings
I was like how are you still thinking
about me you've got you've got so much
going on I I don't I mean it's something
that that I'm honestly inspired by and I
find aspirational
but he does it so well
and it's like he can't do that for
everybody and so uh you know I'm
grateful I guess that he saw something
in me that he'd want to spend that kind
of time with
but he's very selective over who he
brings in and then once you're in he's
he's
going to be the greatest resource of all
time and I think that's how you win
ultimately at least for me I think it's
a fantastic model for me to learn from
and keep trying to do better at and that
how can you win as an introvert when you
are networking
and trying to help people
introverts are great listeners
introverts care we want to help we want
to serve and we can't do it for
everybody because we let too many people
in we then we have no energy for
ourselves
and recognize that that's how you you
that's your secret superpower
let's do superpower
YouTuber power my superpower is to find
just a few people
at every place you go to your goal is
not to meet the whole event it's made a
few people
and figure out how you can help them and
genuinely help them like generally serve
them not not just if I help them do this
and they're gonna help me do that right
we're not don't don't approach it as a
transaction I think introverts are great
at this right it's not on transaction
you we value relationships
but are too afraid to go up and say hi
to people and don't like the The Fluffy
talk
so just make it a goal to find a few
people
and be of service and great things
happen
one of the things I've taken away and
just reinforced from the past couple
days is great things happen to me
and I'm I'm actually becoming less of a
goal person like where do you want to be
next year I have no idea because great
things happen to me
because if you keep pouring into other
people and keep bringing value and keep
helping
great things will happen to you that you
you never thought of
you know that you never thought would
exist and yet here they are now showing
up in your life
and so a challenge for you would be to
think about
whether it's the next event you're going
to or even just some people in your
network
like who do you already know
who are good people
be in the business of collecting good
people like who do you already know
who's a good person who you
you want to serve and help on a deeper
level
and just find a way to reach out and
help them
be of service I make a list of of the
top kind of 100 people that I want to
stay in touch with because I'll forget
I'll forget to stay in touch and two
present-minded Focus but if I haven't
stayed in touch with them in the past 90
days I'll find some some way to help
whether it's
sharing something on social whether it's
making a video giving them some YouTube
advice does just connecting asking how
it can be a resource
I schedule in the ongoing connection
because
these people have helped me a lot and I
want to continue to help them and if
you're just going strategy you know
continue to help successful people will
lead to you having more success because
it will they will find ways to come back
and help you you're almost guilting them
to do it even better is to not even be
as strategic about it
just by putting out good energy just by
serving others just by using that good
karma it comes
and in the process of giving if you can
remind yourself that great things happen
to you
that if I just keep showing up and
serving and helping and doing my very
best every day
great things will happen to me great
things will happen to you great things
will happen to you
you just have to keep going rule number
seven think like an entrepreneur I think
entrepreneurs are going to solve every
problem I think whatever problem there
is in the world entrepreneurs are going
to be the ones to solve it and there's
definitely a place for government and
everything else but I just defaulted
thinking it's us it's entrepreneurs
we're gonna do it we see a problem we
want to fix it be the change you want to
see in the world and and that's really
at the Crux of a successful business
when people ask me how do you make money
as an entrepreneur well you solve a
problem with something that you love
doing if you are solving somebody else's
problem that they're struggling with you
can get paid to do it and if you love
doing that thing then that's how you
start having a business right that can
have success long term sustainable if
you solve a problem but you don't love
doing it you're going to end up burning
out phasing out people will be better
than you at it it won't be sustainable
because you don't love the thing and if
you just love the thing but you're not
solving a problem then you've got a
hobby right if you love doing something
but it doesn't solve anybody's problem
you've got a hobby and it could be
fulfilling and enriching for the soul
but that's not a business it's in that
combination of what solves a real
problem that you enjoy doing that's how
you start to make money I think one of
the biggest problems though for
entrepreneurs is we don't know what the
problem is we think we know what the
problem is but we don't know what the
problem is especially when it's for
ourselves we think that we know what our
problems are but we don't actually know
our problems because we're too in the
thing you ever notice how it's easier to
point out somebody else's problems like
you should be doing this you know the
problem with this business they should
be doing that but it's harder to look at
ourselves and say Here's the biggest
problem that I'm facing right now at
least I find this as a challenge I'm
sitting here at genius Network this is a
it's a what it's a mastermind it's a
success circle
of people who are
having seven eight nine figure
businesses and they meet once a month to
help each other out and one of my
favorite exercises is when you
basically go down and it's called hot
seat and you think about what your
biggest problem is and they put you in
groups and then you're explaining your
problem to the other people in your
group and you get suggestions you get
feedback and these are all you know
peers people who've done equally or
maybe even more things than you have and
it's great to get at least I think a
fresher perspective and so
yesterday one of the members that I was
in that group with
he came up and he said I my biggest
problem is I need to have more structure
in my life I need to be more intentional
with my time I'm too all over the place
I'm I'm too you know creative and and
and I you know it's got me this far but
it's not going to be the thing that gets
me to the next step I need to have more
discipline and schedule
and the first uh person started giving
him some advice and and she was telling
him how she sets her schedule and give
some feedback and
the thing that just kept throwing
flowing through my mind and when it came
to me to give advice I just asked the
question do you even want this
you know like do you even want this
and
he's like
it feels it sounds like prison
as a guy since you've been in prison
before so he knows what that feels like
he's like when I when I think about it
when I talk about it feels like I'm in
prison and that is
a classic case for a lot of
entrepreneurs who want freedom who are
creative who want to be out
like creativity is messy
creativity is messy and so you can't be
productive and you can't be efficient if
you're being creative and knowing a
little bit about him said dude that
that's not your problem see this is
where we got cut up in our own in our
own traps and our own thinking because
we can't self-diagnose very well we
often need people to help us so when he
says
my problem is I'm not being intentional
enough with my time and I'm wasting a
lot of time I need to be more structured
that's not his problem
in fact what he needs to do is the exact
opposite he needs to be spending more
time in his zone of Genius he needs to
be spending more time being creative he
needs to have the freedom to be able to
spend three days swimming with alpacas
if that's the thing that is in his mind
because it's going to lead to some
awesome new creation that if you take a
creative genius like he is and you force
him into a structure and a schedule then
he's going to end up
in a prison like he said and and just
imagine you know if he lives a week like
that versus a month like that versus six
months like that versus a year like that
the more he's trapped in that prison the
less effective he's actually going to be
he might be really efficient and
productive
for a short amount of time but he's
gonna end up hating his life and he's
not going to birth any new creative
things into the world and he's out of
his own of Genius
and so his real problem is he doesn't
have the person on his team to be that
number two to take things over
and he hasn't assigned that person the
responsibilities or given them
permission to be able to to run with
those things he's already built the
seven figure business so it's not like
I'm I'm talking to somebody who's brand
new startup doesn't know what he's doing
right this is a already successful
entrepreneur but again it's easy to spot
the problems in other people's
businesses and other people's lives and
sometimes in our own and so the problem
was different than the problem that he
thought he had
and solving the right Problem by getting
some perspective
will change his life just as I was
talking and expressing
what I thought about him you could see
these starts to come alive and at the
end he's like I feel that and this is
the guy who's really in tune with with
body and energy and is like I feel that
he's like touching his heart you know as
he's doing it and like thank you and
what a gift and so
we solved the right problem
and so
if you are struggling right now
I think one of the best things you can
do is is one model success so go find
the people who've done what you're
trying to do and see what resonates you
know Bill Gates saved my business even
though I've never met him because I had
a software company and I looked at Bill
Gates who started a software company and
that's what I modeled and it started to
work
but I think even more importantly
if you're really struggling right now is
to be around other people who might be
able to help
because you're around some people even
if you're a shy and introverted like me
you saw people some people around you
the problem is they can't tell you what
the problem is you know their their
version of the problem is something you
don't want to hear I don't believe in
negative or toxic people I don't think
that's what's going on but they're
you know hurt people hurt people so they
could be in a lot of pain they could be
hurt they have a different perspective
one that you you don't want their life
you don't respect their opinion on the
thing that you're asking about and so
you just probably around the wrong
people
and to be able to change that to shift
that to you might be able to I mean this
group here one group was 25 000 a year
being the other is a hundred thousand
dollars to be in so
um you may not be able to afford to to
go to a group like that but you don't
need it because the most you don't need
it yet you know the most important thing
is momentum to start building to start
being around more positive optimistic
happy people who you do respect you can
do something with I made a group called
movement makers and every two weeks we
meet and these are people who want to be
thought leaders who want to share want
to help have a message on their heart
and need to get out to the world and
it's great to be around me and I teach
and I share and I give my perspective
but the biggest learning I think
honestly is by them being connected to
each other by them doing challenges and
projects together by them interviewing
each other on their channels so that
they're not alone and they have people
to talk to and connect with and feel
like
like this matters and there's some
momentum because whatever you want to do
the people around you don't understand
it right if you're an entrepreneur
you're a little bit crazy it's awesome
like high five I love you celebrate but
you're a little bit crazy and different
and the people around you don't
understand you and some people might
just be supportive just not know what to
tell you and other people might be
straight out negative and say stop doing
that be practical be realistic go get a
job go to school go X go live a safe
life and you don't want that life
and so you need to start being around
the people collect good people who
support you who cheer you on who believe
in you who say that you can do things
who still push you but in a positive
left and Way Forward as opposed to a
negative way down that makes you feel
like things are possible and so how do
you find those people well
you could join a group right I mean
genius Network might be a fit for you if
you've got a big budget movement makers
might be a fit for you if you're trying
to be a thought leader but but actively
look for people actively look for events
and conferences and groups even if it's
a free meetup group at the beginning
like actively look to be around
people who are close to you or online
groups that you can join but that are
around the same interests of you because
when you're around the people who are
trying to do the same thing that you're
trying to do even if they haven't quite
done it yet it's not only mentoring
where they've done it and they're
showing you the ropes even if it's
they're trying to do it and you're
trying to do it to be around people who
are ambitious who want to chase down
their dream and goals and Achieve
something right and make something of
their lives if you're around those
people it will just fill you with more
energy
it will fill you with more energy and
make you feel like hope is possible
that'd be my median action item to yes
have the environment pay attention to
who you subscribe to on YouTube and who
you follow on Instagram and the books
that you're reading and the content
you're consuming does it lift you up
does it make you feel better and belief
and give you hope and strategies and
tactics on what to actually do and look
at your circle
you know you're with the right people
and if not then just don't don't don't
make it some big thing that you have to
go join this giant group that's super
expensive
just start with
who can I who can I talk to right now
you know who's trying to do this thing
with me too
who's even at my level
that I can build and grow and learn with
and if you just switch your mindset to
start to look to start the search to go
to Google and type in your city and look
for groups or to think about the
industry you want to be in like how to
be a thought leader or how to be a XYZ
whatever it is that you are in whatever
your business is and the fine groups of
people who are doing it you know you
want to be a Toastmasters for speakers
or whatever it is there's a group
so just join and try it because man when
you're around people who are doing
things
it just breathes so much more Life
Energy and momentum into your mission
rule number eight build your limiting
beliefs you have no idea what you're
capable of you have no idea you have no
idea the person you could be the thing
you could accomplish the things you can
do the people you can serve you have no
idea that's why I don't like 10-year
goals 10-year goals think about who you
used to be 10 years ago you know could
that person accurately with any with any
degree of certainty predict where you
could be right now now like if you're
growing and you're learning you're
improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of crew
you should go into right we're told we
should do all these things you're told
you're like who you know nobody ever
thought to ask us what we want for our
lives and you may not even know and
that's okay like you may know where you
want to go next but you may not
ultimately know the Final Destination
it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in in a
year nope
am I still making videos probably but
who knows like question everything I
wanna I want people to believe in
themselves more what's the best way to
do that right now it's through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
playing small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at a genius Network and this group
of super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
knew what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like you you
don't know what the real problem is the
problem you think you have is a problem
you know the problem you think you have
yes very much is a problem but there's a
deeper problem underneath it that you're
missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
uh for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question
and having them trying to fit into my
box I'd rather fit into theirs because
in trying to understand how they process
things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no that's
not going to work for me you know even
boom got a B
I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh
only time in my life I've been sung by
bee and it I was on the floor and my my
back just swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway
maybe question everything except bee
stings how about that uh there's been
times when people giving me advice and
it made sense and it really fit and
sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it but
there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I'll end up doing is making
a new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
following so when creating a new plan
then I have certainty in the plan again
and I'm fine and I'm rock and rolling
but there are some days there are some
days when I can't come up with a new
plan the plan I have I don't believe it
anymore and I'm racking my brain to come
up with a new plan and I can't come up
with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
well what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what I've been great
things happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be a downward spiral like
if I believe in the plan and the plan is
not working and I can't come with a new
plan then I don't know what to do with
my life and that would create a downward
spiral I've never gone anywhere close to
depression or suicide but that would
lead to some dark that could lead to
some dark places and so the way that I
come out of it is just say great things
will happen to me great things happen to
me they already they always happen to me
great things happen to me and I'll
figure this out and that gives me the
Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
um it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in
anxiety-filled that I couldn't come with
a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still a believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change and the change starts with not
just questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen rule
number nine be prepared so I love seeing
how people do their daily routines I
love I love seeing how they start today
I love seeing what their workout
routines are mindset routines are
because
hopefully you can pick up one little
tweak one little hack one of the things
that you can try out on your own to be
able to make your life a little bit
better I'm sitting here outside genius
Network we've just been having some
amazing meetings I spent the past two
days in a group where you pay 25 000 a
year to be in and the next two days we
have to pay a hundred thousand dollars a
year to be in and
um I'm grateful to be able to meet some
amazing humans who build some amazing
businesses so this video leads to a
couple of thoughts for me the first is I
think it's great to have a
healthy balance of ordering chaos most
days you live in order most days you
should have a morning routine most days
you wake up and you do the thing you say
you're going to do most days whether
it's working out or for your business
for your mindset feeding information
into you I go on my believe walks every
morning some of the things I do right
somebody asked me yesterday how do you
say so positive well I go and I believe
walk every morning I go outside get some
sign it's nice here in Arizona let me
show you let me show you I'm it's
snowing right now in in it's I'm filming
this uh the end of April and it's
snowing in in Toronto but I'm here
crazy crazy Sun you know super grateful
we got palm trees in the back I'm gonna
get some of the Sun out of my face but
I go for my believe walk pretty much
every morning and I believe walk what
that is is just helped me set my mind
for the day what do I want to accomplish
today what what am I doing today I
forget you know I forget what my
responsibilities are and why I'm doing
it because no matter how great a day I
had yesterday
today I wake up and feel like I'm
starting over and so having something in
the morning that helps you remind
yourself of the intention that you've
got for today I think is really valuable
it's really helpful at least it is for
me having music on you know putting
music on that makes you bounce makes you
go up and makes you makes you move
because when you move it transforms your
mind as well when your body's moving
your mind starts moving when your body
is slow and lazy and tired then your
mind is slow and lazy and tired as well
and then feeding my brain with with
knowledge with inspiration with it's why
I make all these videos because I want
to learn from the being Gene I want to
learn from Oprah Winfrey I want to learn
from Elon Musk I want to learn from
people who are thinking just way bigger
than me and so I think back to the idea
of order versus chaos most days you
should wake up and and be in order most
days you should wake up and do your
routine most days you should wake up and
do what you said you were going to do
because these are the things that you
know works for you every now and then
though it's great to inject some chaos
because entrepreneurs we love chaos and
it's great to challenge the order and
it's great to see is this thing that I
was doing this is still serving me does
it still work for me is it still
something that I want to be doing and so
that's where going to an event going to
a conference going to meet other people
right so I'm hanging out with all these
successful entrepreneurs here uh in
Arizona and
and it's great and a lot of it is a
reinforcement of what I'm already doing
is working and you hopefully pick up
some nuggets this is what in a 10-day
trip 11 day trip something like that on
my first two days here they gave us uh
free breakfast at the hotel and so my
wife Nina was here with me and we went
for the breakfast the first two days and
I don't usually eat breakfast I don't
usually eat until at least two o'clock
so uh I'll eat between two and six
o'clock every day
sometimes I sometimes I start at two
sometimes I start at six or somewhere in
between I'm usually done by eight and
that's what it is on a daily basis but
since I was away you know you know what
let's have some breakfast and I wasn't
like junking out on every sweet cereal
and syrup all over the place but I
intently kind of went off my routine
still did my belief walk so the music
um and then after two days like you know
what if I keep doing this for the next
10 days 11 days I'm gonna be uh I'm not
gonna feel right you know and so I'm
right now back on my my routine
and the little bit of chaos every now
and then I think is good
it helps you identify is the things that
I'm doing is it working is it helping me
do I want to keep doing it or not what
what does serving me ongoing and so
sometimes you need to get out of your
your environment to to get that shipped
so going to an event going to a complex
meeting other people being around more
ambitious or equally ambitious people as
you can help you
come back with some new ideas even if
you go on vacation you ever go on a
vacation you come back I want to do this
this this and this you feel you feel
rejuvenated you feel energetic you feel
alive you feel ready to go off and just
make some big change right because you
change your environment and so
that will force some chaos into you that
can hopefully lead to some positive
results so I think most days you should
live in the order you know here's my
routine and I think it works and I'm
sticking to it and then every now and
then you need to inject a little bit of
chaos into it and hopefully in that
chaos it's something positive that
you're injecting into yourself that
makes you pause makes you reflect and
makes you see is this order that I set
up for myself still lead me to the life
that I want one of the things that I
have taken away from the past two days
of hanging with the 25k a year members
is the importance of tracking and right
now what I've done then is started
tracking
what time I eat every day
and what how many uh push-ups Jumping
Jacks and squats that I'm doing every
day and one of the speakers was talking
about in in general as entrepreneurs
what we're always trying to do is go for
new highs what's our new high break our
break a break a new record right go for
new highs where
a great way to think about it is instead
of always trying to break new highs
because that's
almost impossible to do
just work on your bad days work on
lowering the raising the lows so if
you're thinking about a health goal for
example and you want to you want to hit
a certain weight well you're the average
of what you've done for the past year
right if you if you eat like crap half
the time and eat super healthy half the
time you're gonna get a certain weight
outcome if you eat or fast some days but
then eat super junky other days you'll
get a certain weight outcome so you're
the average of all your highs and lows
and we tend to focus only on the highs
and we don't focus enough on the lows
where if you can just instead of always
focusing on getting better highs just
lowering the impact of the lows then you
can get a better average result which is
what your end result ends up being and
so
you don't know until you track it so if
you're on a health Journey there may be
days you eat super clean awesome and you
can eat cleaner on some days great but
you'll probably get the best results by
those days where you fall off the rails
where you cheat where you make yourself
not so proud where if I'm having
breakfast at the buffet at the hotel on
the bad days you don't let it go too bad
this is the concept of bumpers like in a
bowling alley you have bumpers down the
side and so you don't let it get too bad
and so if you cheat or you eat then
you're not having all like pounds of
syrup and everything else that you
minimize the impact or if you're gonna
if you're gonna work out you're gonna
make your calls you're gonna make some
videos that whatever your worst days are
just making them not as bad
and track so by track and you can see
how well you're doing and so I started
tracking what time I ate so yes it was
the first day so I ate at 6 15. I didn't
do anything all day eight at 6 15 at
night and ended up doing
50 push-ups 100 squats and 200 jumping
jacks something like that and then today
I'll start tracking again and it gives
you a baseline for where you're at and
so that's a new thing that I'm gonna try
and right now my plan is tracked those
metrics what time I ate how many
push-ups Jumping Jacks and squats that I
do every day those four things that I'm
measuring and track that every day just
on a piece of paper and then on the
weekend transfer that into a Google
sheet and uh so I have historic data now
here's the thing it's an idea right now
I'm super excited about the idea I'm
away from my environment of injected
chaos into it and I got inspired to do
this so immediate action I'm doing it
right you don't have to wait to go home
to buy a Fitbit to buy a fancy tracker
to XYZ right this is what we tend to do
you get inspired by something and then
you go off and you plan and plan and
plan and when when I get home or next
week or next month or on my birthday or
New Year I'm gonna do it I said just do
it just get started just just immediate
imperfect action is always the answer
and I'm excited by it right now and it
might be that might make a huge
difference to me it might be a big game
changer it might be all like talk about
you know to to give you advice for the
next 10 years of my life or maybe it
Fizzles out you know or maybe I try it
for three days and I leave here in a
couple days and then that's it and I
don't do it again it's still worth the
experiment and that's what chaos brings
the chaos brings new ideas and the
newness is not productive the newness is
creative but the newness is gonna fail a
lot the newness is not going to be
efficient again it won't be productive
and we judge ourselves that every new
idea has to be the perfect idea it's
that's it's the exact opposite
you know like new ideas most of them
will fail it's not that it's a bad idea
it just made it be the right idea for
you at this moment in your life right
now
and so I'm trying it but in general back
to the idea of ordering chaos I think
most days you wake up and have a
schedule
I think most States should wake up and
do the thing at least talking to myself
Evan Carmichael Evan most days you
should wake up and have a schedule we'll
see if you wake up and do the thing that
you said you were going to do and have
your routine and stick to it because
that has consistently gotten new results
and if you keep doing that you'll keep
getting more results
and every now and then you need to
inject a little bit of chaos into it you
need to be around other people who are
doing big things you need to question
the order and question the structure and
ask yourself does this structure right
now still serve me and is there a better
way
and it's in that combination that I
think you ultimately find your happiness
your success your purpose
and um yeah you get the life that you
want rule number 10 the last one before
our very special bonus clip Embrace and
release fear my biggest fear is
disappointing people my biggest fear is
that people will watch one of my videos
will buy my book we'll come to one of my
seminars or speeches or whatever and
feel like well that was a giant waste of
time I don't know um
ultimately where it comes from but
that's my biggest fear and it's and it's
honestly
made me play small
my whole life
and the the trick that I found is that I
just need to when I can recognize it I
can do something about it I think most
of the time we play small by default
most of the time we find a reason why we
can't do something and we justify the
reason we believe the reason so for
example if I'm afraid to make videos
in the beginning I was very afraid to
make videos and I wouldn't make a video
until my friend would come and film it
and I looked professional I had to have
the perfect script and if you go back
and watch my first video I did it on
Walt Disney's story and it was filmed
professionally by my friend Mark Drager
shout out to you and uh I had the
perfect script and I was trying to
memorize it and I couldn't memorize
enough and so I was mostly voice over
where I read a script And I memorized a
few lines and then we did b-roll over
over my talking points because I was so
concerned that if I said the wrong thing
then people might be disappointed that's
taken a lot of unwinding to do I used to
with interviews I used to want to know
what the questions were going to be in
advance
because I felt like I want to be able to
give good answers I didn't want to
discipline the audience of whoever you
know if I'm being interviewed on
somebody's show I want I want them to
have a great show I don't want to be a
terrible guest
you know I want I want them to feel like
this was really valuable and that I
shared my best information and knowledge
and gave Great Value to Their audience
and so I I always wanted to know what
questions do you want to have of an
answer or have me answer that ended up
being a
mistake because when I knew the
questions I could give good information
but it it was almost robotic because the
answers were rehearsed
where what I've learned is it's much
more about the emotion than it is about
the exact words people remember how you
make them feel Maya Angelou right people
will remember how you make them feel and
if everything is memorized and perfect
and scripted then the feeling isn't
there because you're so worried about
memorizing and seeing the exact right
word that then there's no emotion there
there's no emotion in what you're saying
and what you're creating what you're
producing then it's not going to move
anybody to any kind of action
and that took a lot of unwinding to do
to be honest and it led me to the point
where whenever I can catch it it's like
how do you get through it whenever you
can catch it
take the action that would make you
proud
so this is you know a decade plus of me
unwinding this and taking slow progress
in action and hopefully you can get
there a lot faster by even just
recognizing that as a problem and
watching videos like this but I did a
couple things so anytime you can catch
it you take the action to make you proud
so
why do I want to have all the questions
in advance of an interview well The
Logical story in my head is because I
want to give a lot of value to the
audience underneath that is the fear
that I'm going to disappoint them oh
it's showing up again okay so now I have
to take corrective action which is I
don't want to have any questions in
advance
which freaked me out right like but what
if x happens
it freaked me out because it freaked me
out I had to go off and do it you know
you start to teach yourself are you the
kind of person who does the things that
freak you out or not
I don't think I had any total train
wrecks or total disasters
but I end up making everything so much
stronger so much better and so much more
fun too that I could just be myself and
show up and answer questions and have a
much better time with the host than than
otherwise than me being stressed out
about getting the right right answers
done all the time on the flip side for
doing interviews
I would always stress out too about
disappointing the guests and
disappointing the audience and feeling
like I I mean I would stress out I think
about having Tony ROMs on the channel or
Matthew McConaughey on the channel or
all these people that I've interviewed
on the channel
honestly the beginning maybe a week
leading up to it I'd be I'd be stressed
out
researching memorizing asking myself
what questions I want to ask running the
story over and over and over and over
and over and over again in my mind in my
head just a wreck I was a total wreck
that's all I could focus on because I'm
so stressed out about doing a good
interview
and getting their story out and giving
value to them and to you guys and not
you know the fear underneath that is
disappointing anyone's disappoint Tony I
didn't want to disappoint you guys in
the audience and
the breaking of that came down to you
know what it's going to be a lot better
if it's more natural it doesn't mean I
stopped doing research but my solution
has been
I find an angle that I want to pull on I
find the thread that I want to pull on
and once I find that thread I stop
stressing and worrying about the
interview
so yesterday I had Alex hermosi on my
channel and we did an Instagram live and
I don't know Alex super well we've
connected a little bit on on DMS on
Instagram but I've never done a
interview never haven't met him yet in
person at least at the time of this
recording and I watched some of his
videos and I looked at his story and I
found the angle that I wanted to to go
down I wanted I found the thread I
wanted to pull on and once I did that I
stopped researching the story
and now I can get to within a couple
hours
of researching somebody knowing what I
want to talk to them about
and where we can find our conversation
will be different than others and and I
still I still stress out before an
interview
before I'm I'm interviewing somebody
but it's now maybe an hour you know it's
it's 45 minutes or an hour of stressing
out as opposed to a week
I've played small my whole life based
off of this fear of disappointing other
people who is going to see me fail and
and are they gonna feel like they wasted
their time or money and as a result
it's led to a much
smaller life and lower impact and what
I'm capable of doing
and similar for you you know you've got
fears and insecurities and doubts and
worried about judgment or losing love or
whatever it is and it's keeping you
small and the point of that is not to
beat yourself up it's not to beat myself
up and say oh wow I suck now because I'm
not I'm not doing it it's to realize hey
I've still got a long life ahead you've
still got so many years ahead of you to
live the life that you wanted to have a
big impact and to build a business that
you want to build you you can still do
all of that and recognizing what your
biggest fear is
will allow you to tackle it will allow
you to stop listening to the reasons
right reasons in your head as to why you
can't do something but underneath that
is just fear you're not going to believe
a stupid reason right you're a smart
person so you're going to believe really
smart reasons so our brain comes up with
really smart reasons why we can't do
something right oh I can't make YouTube
videos because I don't have the right
gear and the right camera and the right
phone and the the Right microphone and
the right speech and what's my topic
going to be and what's the thumbnail
going to be and I don't know editing yet
and I don't know what to call it I don't
know the description and do tags still
work and you spend all this time
researching and over analyzing over
stressing because you want it to be
perfect and you've trained yourself that
these are all really value valid reasons
until you believe it but underneath all
of that is really just fear
your fear of it not working you're free
you're afraid of that it will work and
who will see it you're free that it
won't work and people won't see it
you're afraid of being judged you're
afraid of looking a certain way it's
just fear it's just fear the reason why
you're not doing the thing that you want
to do you have you have goals you have
an ambition you have a mission you have
a vision for what you want to create and
the reason why you're not doing it is
because you're afraid you're afraid of
something
and we've convinced ourselves with
logical reasons why you can't do it but
really you're just afraid underneath all
of that is just fear and if you can
tackle the fear all of a sudden the
logical reasons go away
because underneath it was just fear you
could start your YouTube video you could
I mean I'm sitting here in my car on my
phone while Nina's in Costco look you
can see Nina's in Costco I'm sitting in
the parking lot
making this video you know it's
and so when you can catch what the thing
is that you're afraid of
that fear
I don't think that it goes away it just
shows up in in bigger versions of it so
I'm still afraid of disappointing people
but it's just now on a bigger scale the
things that you know doing an interview
I'm not as afraid of anymore
interviewing others I'm not as afraid of
anymore even this like filming in public
I used to be terrified of doing this I'm
filming in public like there's like
people oh
I'm gonna shoot because they're looking
at me they're people are packing up
their cars and unloading their groceries
and I would always judge and worry like
oh if I'm gonna do something outside it
should be like we're at the back of the
parking lot because what do people walk
past me and they're judging me and
they're looking at me I could never have
done this you know however many years
ago and now we're here so once you
conquer that fear
it allows you to keep doing that same
thing but the same fear shows up on a
bigger scale
so I'm not as afraid to do an interview
but I'm afraid to do interview on a
bigger show or I'm afraid to go off and
and speak on a giant stage and the trick
is to catch the fear not believe the
excuse or the reasons why we can't do
that thing and teach yourself that you
become the person who does the things
that are scary
your entire great life is on the other
side of your fears everything that you
want out of life and the impact you want
to have and the business you want to
build the money you want to make is on
the other side of you taking on those
fears because you've got the heart
you've got the passion you've got the
soul you've got the desire to serve
you've got it you've got it all
you're just afraid and that's normal and
that's okay
the trick is to not succumb to the fears
to rise up to them to meet them head on
and go build the life that you want
practice gives you ultimate Freedom the
more you practice the better you get at
something the more skilled you are at it
the more information you have the more
it actually allows you to play more have
more fun be more flexible and have
ultimately more freedom this is
something I struggled with a lot in the
early days of my speaking career I was
asked to speak at a bunch of events and
this is what 20 years ago I guess I've
I've had as a speaking career now and I
used to be so worried about
disappointing people that I would
memorize my entire speech I would
practice and practice and practice and
practice and practice and just memorize
my speech to the point where
word for word it would be the exact same
thing every time and I thought that was
good I thought that's what you're
supposed to do obviously yes practice
makes perfect keep going keep practicing
keep doing it and what ended up
happening was yes I delivered the same
speech each time but I think the worst
thing you can do as a speaker is just
give the exact same speech every time
we did a session of Movie Makers around
the signature talk it was one of the
most voted topics was how do I give my
signature talk and I think having one
signature talk is actually not great I
think you should be able to
be able to speak to the audience every
time your job if you're a speaker is to
give your audience a fantastic
experience and so it's knowing who's in
the audience don't assume it's the same
people every single time
right so you have to be able to know so
much about your subject that then you
can have your framework that you operate
in but then give a lot more value to
People by making a custom to them
so now whenever I'm doing a speaking gig
I'm always asking okay tell me about the
audience tell me who's here tell me why
people are setting it up what what are
people here for both in terms of the
information they're hoping to get as
well as their background and their
interests and their concerns and what
they struggle with and of course there's
genuine human struggles that everybody
goes through but why are people here at
this conference and so here's my process
right now when I'm doing a a speech or
talk
they're gonna have me coming they're
going to talk about believer
entrepreneurship or YouTube there's
gonna be some set themes you're not
having me come to talk about my apple
strudel recipe
I have one right I'm coming and talking
about things that are inside my domain
perfect
and I could easily just get up on stage
and talk
but I want to know who's in the audience
so before going I'll ask them tell me
about the people who are going to be
here and then I'll frame my speech
around a couple of key ideas that I
think would be valuable to that audience
still sitting within kind of the my
usual domain perfect
I'll practice it I'll practice giving a
speech I'll practice the points at home
I'll practice I'll practice talking to
my dog I'll practice on the airplane on
the way over I'll practice to kind of
get a sense of the stories that I want
to tell that I think will be the right
fit
but then the day before and the day of I
like to be there a little early to to
talk to people to one makes me feel a
little more comfortable
um
be able to connect the people in the
audience so it's not just
people I don't know but I've had a few
conversations with people but two
in feeling the vibe out of the event
I'll often end up switching up part of
my talk again to make it as customizable
as possible to the people I'm talking to
and this isn't just a speaking thing
guys this is any interaction you're
doing you're trying to sell your product
trying to sell your service you're on a
call with somebody who could use your
product service hire you as a coach
Etc you have to customize your pitch
customize your talk for them not just
give the same thing every single time
you're talking to somebody you have to
know what makes them tick know why
they're talking to you what their their
deep desires and fears are and address
those things so that you can close the
sale right it's the same thing I'm just
giving an example through speaking
has been willing to deviate
from your talk
to actually give more value
and I think again the worst thing you
can do is the speakers just give get on
stage you can get the same talk every
single time
that's what I used to think was the way
to go but this is actually a lot more
valuable
because you can inspire people but when
it becomes boring for you to get up and
just do the same thing over and over and
over again and two if you can customize
it to actually address the thing that
they're specifically concerned about
you're gonna have a bigger impact why
are you there you're there to touch
people you're there to move people to a
positive direction right
again whether whether you're speaking or
you're just talking to somebody on the
phone a potential client why are you
working with them yes they're going to
pay you but why you want them to get a
result you want them to move you want
them to make a change you want to solve
a problem for them and so the more you
can actually connect to what they're
struggling with the easier it is for you
to
to close a sale and have the impact that
you're trying to have so it's a lot more
fun it's a lot more impactful a lot more
meaningful and so that's my usual
process now why are people here
I'll prepare a version of my speech to
address those people and then it always
changes up the day of because I met
somebody in the lobby who inspired me or
I met somebody on the airplane the day
before who shifted my thinking a little
bit and gives me an extra story to tell
and when you're so prepared and you know
your stuff so much it's easy to add
those things in
when you don't really know
you're kind of all over the place
so it's being overly prepared and then
the day of being willing to be flexible
it's that like rigidity of practice and
practice and practice and knowing what
you're doing so much that allows you to
play when you show up it's the you know
going to sports you practice your free
throws so much you practice your penalty
shot so much you practice you practice
so much that allows you to be a lot more
flexible to play when it comes to game
time let me share another quick example
from the opposite side where I was
interviewing somebody so instead of
being the person on stage speaking I'm
interviewing somebody and I recently had
Tony Robbins on the channel and it was
the third time I came on the channel the
first two interviews we did had three
million views on them combined which is
amazing and he's coming back for the
third time talk about his new book and
I'm always nervous before a big
interview and this is probably the least
nervous I've been because it's the third
time on but I was still nervous going in
and so I'm preparing I'm preparing and
preparing and preparing I'm trying to
find a thread that I care about I don't
want to just ask the same questions
everybody else has asked I don't want to
just use the questions that his PR
agency sent over because he's going to
answer those questions on every other
show I want it to be different and
unique and fun and special and so I
prepared I know I've got
uh half an hour with him uh I know he
likes to go long in his toys you don't
get that many questions in so I need to
I need to really be careful of what I'm
gonna say and make this time count
it'd be easy just to show up and ask
okay why did you write this book what
does it mean to you what do you hope
people get from it what was your
favorite part about it and then then
half an hour is done and you haven't
really asked anything super meaningful
so I'm preparing
and I wrote down on a notepad file that
I had opened when I was talking to him
you know four questions five questions
that I wanted to ask and I practice how
I would ask them I practice you know
what what I was going to say
and then I practiced it so much that
come game time come show time here we go
Tony's coming on let's let's do our
one-on-one
I was able to actually be present and
listen to what I was saying and and play
ball with him right to to throw and
catch with him instead of just going to
the questions when you haven't prepared
and you're really insecure you just go
to the questions you just go okay here's
what I said okay here and just ask the
question we're the best interviews are
when you can throw and catch right where
they say something and you take that a
little bit deeper as opposed to just
moving on to the next question because
I've watched a lot of interviews and in
the work that I do and one of the things
that I find most frustrating is the
person says something amazing and you
want them to it's like okay ask a
follow-up question and instead of asking
a follow-up question then just go to the
next question
because the interviewer it was never
even listening to what the interviewee
was saying they're just so worried about
getting the next question in that that's
that's all they're thinking about and so
like okay great and then tell me about
this next question without going deeper
into the conversation so I didn't want
to be that kind of interviewer even I
get it because you're nervous
you're not fully prepared you're worried
about the questions
so one example with Tony he was talking
about a recent Health scare that he had
and that his career would be over
the doctor said your career is over
and in my head I was thinking about some
of the other stuff I knew about Tony
Robbins and so I asked him how many
times have you been told that your
career is over
it was off script right it wasn't
something his team prepared it wasn't
something Tony's maybe been asked and I
asked him how many times have you been
told that your career has been over
because I remember uh you know he had
this
um tumor that made him grow crazy
quickly and and people said his life
would be over I remember he burned out
his voice box and his doctors told him
he'd never speak on stage again and now
this injury that happened to him he
wasn't gonna be able to go into his
event so he's been told consistently
that his career would be over
and yet he still gets up and he finds a
way and he does it right one of the
things that we love about his ability to
follow through and stay consistent and
so in the over preparation and knowing
his story and also knowing that I had
questions to fall back on in case
there was a lull on the conversation it
allows the play it allows the freedom it
allows you to adjust the situation which
then creates a much better experience so
whether you're speaking whether you're
interviewing whether you're coaching
whether you're mentoring whether you're
on a sales call
you need to know your script you need to
know what you're going to say you need
to understand your customer and who
you're talking to you need to know all
that and over prepare
but then understand that the greatest
asset that you have is not in rehearsing
again the script is that you have the
ability to be free now
that you can play because you've done
all the drills and now you need to have
the back and forth it's it's throwing
and catching I'm gonna throw the ball to
you you're gonna catch it you're gonna
throw the ball back to me it's not just
throwing where a lot of times the
biggest mistake is that you're just
throwing you're just throwing another
one and another one and here's my other
line here's my next question here's my
next pitch throw throw throw throw
and the person I'd be saying but there's
no receiving and them throwing the ball
back to you that's the best part in any
interaction if you have a goal to get
them to move forward to make a change in
their life just to sign you up to hire
you to work with you so you can make
that impact that you're trying to make
there has to be that back and forth and
the more prepared you are the easier it
is to then have the freedom to play
embrace the and most people are thinking
or most people are thinking do I do this
or do this do I do this business or do
this business if you think about your
passions and your interests right what
do you love doing what's your heart
centered thing that you could do all day
you probably have a couple things and
you feel like you have to pick this is
the mistake people feel like you have to
pick you don't have to pick the actual
selection is in doing both of those
things combined a lot of people have
said some amazing things of me is very
humbling I think of Ed mylett and
garyvee where garyvee called me the DJ
that likes to watch so much content and
then spin it to inspire people and Ed
mylett said that I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill Napoleon Hill is the
biggest influence of all time personal
development and I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill first off that's
extremely humbling but
why are they saying that this is how I'm
unique because I love consuming all of
this stuff and I love spinning it and
mixing it up as well as adding my own
message to things this is how I'm
Different there's a lot of people who
are just sharing their message and
there's a lot of people who are also
mixing things together but there's
nobody who's really mixing things
together and sharing their own message
right so instead of looking at those two
things as different Brian's like I have
to pick I got to pick this or this like
I'm going to combine them and that's how
I'm going to be unique so think about
your different interests what do you
love doing what are what are your top
two three things that you can get lost
in and they feel completely different
your Genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
usually not to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end you have Michael Jordan level Talent
at something but instead of being world
class at that thing you settle for being
just above average at something that you
should not be doing Albert Einstein once
said everybody is a genius but if you
judge a fish by its ability to climb a
tree it will believe its whole life that
it is stupid that's most people's
problems you are a fish
and you're trying to climb a tree
instead of going and being great at
swimming this is the exact problem that
I'm on a mission to solve so I recently
had a young entrepreneur come to one of
my Toronto q a meetups that are free
that I host every week and he said Evan
I have a problem I'm trying to decide
between what my parents want me to be
which is an architect and what I feel uh
yearning towards which is being a
musician and I don't know what to do I
know how to decide I don't know how I'm
going to be a success as a musician I
don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and this is clearly defined
path for how to do it and he's afraid
I think that's so many people there's a
safe perfect path that has been designed
that people have done forever and ever
and ever and ever and ever or this is
new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people and you do what they want
you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it it's never been easier to
actually be yourself and build a
business and have success being uniquely
you right this was not open to your
parents and definitely not your
grandparents the ability to be an
entrepreneur on the side making money
using your phone is something that your
grandparents don't understand it's just
it's totally wild and so you are a
unique individual right you are I am we
all are you have unique interests
personality traits belief systems you're
unique you need to do something unique
if you are unique you need to do
something unique if you're stuck doing
the same thing that somebody else wants
you to do you're never going to be happy
now there may be some alignment you may
not absolutely hate the job that you're
at but you know you're capable of more
you're Michael Jordan
you are the Michael Jordan of something
you're a genius and absolute Bonafide
genius at something this is why I think
it's the world's greatest problem this
is why I do what I do every single day
in making this content videos for you
because I want to unlock people
hopefully more than one at a time but
even if it's just one person who watches
this video and gets unlocked I'm pumped
because I think if everybody is off
doing the thing that they are a genius
at man I want to live in that world how
you think about the problem is the
problem most people are locked into
losing thinking finding all the reasons
why you won't win if you're the ant
think about how you can kill the
elephant if you're the elephant think
about how you can kill the ant the
problem is not the problem how you think
about the problem is the problem so I
used to think that introverts couldn't
win I used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a YouTube channel to to
be an entrepreneur that introverts can't
win and for the longest time I hid
behind the faces on my website so before
even starting YouTube I started on my
website it was called devincharmacle.com
I didn't have a better name at the time
and I profiled different successful
entrepreneurs basically what I do on
YouTube but on my website because I
wanted to share the stories model and
success saved my business and I wanted
to make it easier for other people to be
able to get success on their own as well
so learn who's done it apply those
strategies make it work for you and
let's go and so I always hid behind the
faces I remember my first banner I had
Howard Hughes a big Howard Hughes uh
Oprah Winfrey and a couple of people and
people kept asking me well where is Evan
Carmichael you know the website's off
your name you're putting this together
what's your story and I thought well who
cares about my story I mean sure I built
and sold my first business but it's
nothing compared to Howard Hues and
Oprah Winfrey's people who've done great
things and it kept coming up over and
over and over again translate that to my
YouTube channel Evan Carmichael was
still the number one requested top ten
and when I first started doing top tens
we did Kanye West shout out to Kanye
there on the wall and then a bunch of
other people people kept asking for mine
like well what do you want mine you mean
again what have I done compared to Kanye
West and I always hid behind the fact
that I was an introvert and so I don't
want to share my story nobody is
interested I'm shy I'm I'm the
Wallflower I don't go off and try to
make myself the center of attention I
don't like you know hanging out with
people and so I had the story that
introverts Can't Win It wasn't until I
reframed it and thought you know what
introverts can win
in Communications because we're better
listeners I'm a great listener as much
as you might think I love talking and
making these videos and seeing the
speeches that I do what I love doing
more than that is listening and I think
that's how you win as an introvert
because it's not about you just sharing
sharing sharing talk talk look at me
it's you're trying to help and I've met
some amazing introverts who are on a
huge Mission and why not have a big
impact and have to fight with themselves
to get out of their comfort zone and
have the spotlight on them instead of
just being behind the scenes but they're
all great listeners they become great
communicators because they're great
listeners and so the problem wasn't that
I'm an introvert the problem is how I
thought about the problem of being an
introvert take some kind of immediate
action
most people's immediate action is
research
planning that's not enough immediate
action is doing you have to do something
and you don't know where to start this
is the next thing yeah I don't know
where to start I want to start a YouTube
channel I don't know where to start you
start by pulling out your phone and
making a video I'm in my car on my phone
making a video
you can too
it's not worrying about it being perfect
it's expecting to suck and just start
just create
I called the two percent difference is
for like what's the first two percent on
your idea we plan to get to 100 instead
of just going and doing something on the
first two percent
whatever that big idea is
start to teach yourself that your ideas
are amazing the ideas of Flow To You are
good
they're good for you they're good for
your family they're good for your
community they're good for the world
they're good and you have a duty to
start doing something towards them start
to train yourself on this recently I
wanted to learn about nfts and
cryptocurrency and I've dabbled and
learned a little bit but I just decided
I'm gonna I'm gonna figure this out
and last week on Friday I spent the day
learning it and I had all sorts of
obstacles thrown in my way I couldn't
get money out of my bank account because
my bank blocked cryptocurrency purchases
my Visa blocked cryptocurrency purchases
there's a whole bunch of restrictions as
a Canadian to buy from the different
exchanges all sorts of problems all sort
and you know what like one problem after
another after another my my U.S bank
account like well I've got a US account
with TD so I'm gonna go to my us account
no problem
the TD was closed the online banking had
a had a update that their website
crashed like oh my gosh it's like
non-stop but we figured it out built
some momentum started taking some kind
of action
and makes a huge huge huge huge
difference because while you're feeling
the Bold energy if you wait till
tomorrow you won't feel the energy
anymore you can have the perfect plan
but tomorrow you won't have the same
mindset and so you won't execute the
plan there is no work-life balance
there's just life
the fact that we are separating work
from life
I think is a big problem I think that's
why most people hate their life because
we don't see work as a part of life your
work is a part of life your work should
fuel your life your work should give you
purpose and meaning we all want to wake
up and feel like we matter and we're
gonna do something today in our work
that's going to create some kind of
positive impact right on the days when
you wake up and you feel like today is
gonna matter I'm gonna make something
that is going to matter to another human
being maybe a million people maybe one
person but today is gonna matter those
are the days that you love your life and
you feel amazing and you feel like
you're contributing and you feel like
this is yes this is why I do what I do
and on the days when you feel like it
doesn't matter nobody cares if you show
up you're not making anything meaningful
there is no contribution those are the
days where you hate your life
there is no work-life balance guys it's
just life
when I'm on podcasts and people ask me
this question like what does work-life
balance mean to you or they ask me some
variation of it like how many hours a
day do you work or what is your work
calendar look like it's like well what
what's work to you is my usual response
you know I'm sitting here on your show
I'm having a great time we're doing this
podcast together
is this work for you
like does this count as work because I
don't see this as work
this isn't work this is fun
this is fun for me this is my life I
like this when I see this podcast in my
calendar I'm excited by it I don't look
at it as work
making these videos I don't see it as
work that's why I've been able to stay
so consistent
right how do I not burn out it's another
question to get asked how do you not
burn out how do you make so many videos
how do you not burn out
a lot of people burn out
nowhere even close to the number of
videos that that I've done over
how many years 13 years
a lot of years guys it's been a lot of
years they're showing up and making
over 10 000 videos crazy how why well
because it doesn't feel like work this
this is part of my life
it's a it's this is what a purposeful
life looks like if I saw it as work I
would have quit and given up
years ago I mean a decade plus ago
there are some pieces of
what I do that feels like work you know
doing accounting stuff feels like work I
hate that stuff doing administrative
stuff paperwork legal stuff that feels
like work I burn out very quickly I
don't want to spend I want to spend the
least amount of time as possible on that
I want to hire people have a great
lawyer have a great account and have a
great bookkeeper have people help me
with that stuff because I do not enjoy
it it feels like work and if my calendar
was just filled with that stuff I would
hate my life
so I I don't I don't believe in work
life balance I I reject the the premise
of the entire question
it's just life
how do you want to spend your life and
this is one of the greatest things that
we have as entrepreneurs you get to
decide what your life is you get to pick
the business you go into you don't have
a boss besides the customers but you
still also get to pick which customers
that you work with
and your your work
should be something that is a source of
joy for you and a source of energy for
you because when you love what you're
doing every day it will bring you a lot
more happiness and satisfaction in your
life
so it's all just life
one of the great things I think that you
can do
is look at your calendar see what's
coming up in the next couple weeks a
couple months and are you excited to buy
the things that are in your calendar
and I I put everything in my calendar I
love living by my calendar
um
I don't know if it's because I don't
remember what I'm doing you know
tomorrow or I'm so present focused that
I don't know what's I don't know what
I'm supposed to be doing tomorrow so I
have it in my calendar and it I think it
also reduces anxiety for me to know that
I've got days for things so making
videos I don't worry during the week
about making videos because I know on
Tuesday it's my video day and I'll get
it all done and if I get an idea for
video I'll email myself and I'll look at
that on Tuesday so it's in my calendar
so I have I have a spot for everything
so I'm not constantly worried before I
had a calendar I'd be worried and
anxious about oh when am I going to get
this done when do I have time to do this
and that would stress me out we're now
like okay I know I'm I'm gonna do that
on Tuesday when am I gonna have time to
Mentor my team oh okay we're gonna all
right Monday we're not gonna time to
have you know
um clean up the condo and and do grocery
shopping whatever okay that's Sunday
right so it's all in the calendar so
at least for me having a calendar has
been life-changing
but what ends up happening is we we
don't put everything in our calendar we
just put our meetings in our calendar
where I put everything I put I put time
with Nina my calendar time with my son
and my calendar uh time
playing League of Legends and Minecraft
is in my calendar you know stuff is it's
in my calendar so I have I have time to
get everything I want out of life done
you have time
this this reason I've I don't have time
like if if I was to step into your life
and see what you were doing every day
there's a lot of wasted time
it's a lot of unintentional time
so the whole idea of having a calendar
is to be more intentional be more
intentional with how you're spending
your time
and if you do that then
you can look at your week ahead your
month ahead and are you excited this is
all life right forget where like balance
is all life so you look at your life
what's in your calendar are you excited
by the things that are in there
are you excited by the projects you're
working on are you excited by the people
you're going to be connecting with are
you excited by the amount of time you're
spending just to yourself whether that's
meditation or yoga or working out or
swimming or walking or whatever are you
spending enough time just for you
are you excited about the life that is
in your calendar and if not then change
it what are we doing here this is why
you became an entrepreneur
if you want to live somebody else's
version of your life go get a job where
you're told what to do you're told when
to show up you're told what you have to
work on that's that's a job that's why
most people hate their lives because
they're being told what to do constantly
all the time they have no freedom
if you want to be an entrepreneur and
have ultimate freedom
then let's take control of our calendar
because we're not
most entrepreneurs that I meet are feel
out of control
are wasting a ton of time feel like
they're not spending their time being
intentional know they're capable of so
much more know they can be a lot more
efficient a lot more productive a lot
more purposeful
with how they're spending their time
so if there's nothing in your calendar
that's exciting you
then you you do not like your life
because your calendar is reflection of
how you're spending your life
so change it now maybe that's a drastic
change
or maybe that's a minor change
and this is an ongoing evolution
whenever I feel
unhappy
uh not like depressed because that
doesn't really happen but when I'm
feeling
when I'm feeling that the energy is off
probably a better way to put it whenever
I feel like the energy is off for one
day not the end of the world right for
one day
just go do the thing that's in your
calendar because you said you were gonna
do it right but if this happening for a
couple days in a row or if it's
happening for Tuesdays is my filming day
for example if I had two or three
Tuesdays in a row where I feel the
energy is really off
and I'm not enjoying making videos
then I need to Pivot and it's either I
need to
make different kinds of videos
or I need you to stop making videos
that may happen I'm willing to drop
things if it doesn't bring me joy
anymore
and we as humans stay in things for far
too long like there are things that
you're holding on to that you should
have dropped maybe years ago and you're
still doing it why because it's a habit
a routine or or it's sunk cost like you
had this goal five years ago that
doesn't even matter to you anymore but
you've built your self-identity around
it be willing to let go of things sooner
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate
and so there may come a day where
I just dropped my YouTube channel all of
them because it doesn't fill me with joy
anymore now I don't think that's gonna
happen anytime soon because I still love
doing this stuff
most people have not taken control of
their schedules you wake up like an
accident start responding to other
people's emergencies and help other
people build their dreams instead of you
building yours it's time for a change
you deserve better and this video is
going to show you how I think one of the
biggest reasons why so many
entrepreneurs don't take enough action
is because when you get motivated you
don't do enough you feel the motivation
you feel the boldness feel the
confidence but you're not taking enough
action you're not doing enough I
remember going to my first Tony Robbins
event this is before uh I knew Tony
one-on-one before I did the interview
with him on my channel I just went to
see what would the event be like I've
I've seen so many different videos of so
many different people and I felt like
you know what for most people going to
their event it'd probably be the same as
just watching on YouTube but for Tony I
felt you know what I think his event
might be different there's something
that tells me by going to his event
it'll be different than what I just see
on YouTube through the content and so I
went I went with my wife I went with
three people on my team I paid for
everyone to go out and went to our first
Tony Robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to Tony Robbins event it's on
fire you're you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging
you're high-fiving you're you're
breaking through limits it's it's
amazing by the end of the last day you
see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out where everybody's all pumped
up and energized like I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that
I remember one of the people that I
brought with me he's like yeah yeah I'm
gonna do all this stuff and he's like
yelling and so fired up and excited he's
like what are you doing Evan like I'm
looking at my calendar
because
this is why so many people fall off you
go to an event like that and then you
fall off because you're not making a
consistent success is habits so whenever
you decide to make a change you have to
at least for me I look immediately to my
calendar
so if my goal is now I want to be a big
YouTuber great when am I going to make
videos it's got to be in the calendar
it's not in the calendar it's never
going to happen and so anytime you want
to make a meaningful change you have the
default to thinking what am I going to
put into my calendar because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you maybe
Events maybe books podcasts awesome
you're getting it from somewhere you
feel motivated great show me in your
calendar where you are spending the time
to actually make the thing happen
otherwise you're just living off some
fumes you know you get motivated for a
day or two it feels amazing and then you
fall back down to normal if you want
that dream life you want that next step
for yourself it's gonna come from
changing your habits changing what's in
your calendar to make sure that what you
say you want out of life you're actually
working towards making that happen hope
without action leads to pain and
suffering watching videos like this is
not enough it might give you hope but
hope that is not tied to action and you
doing something will mean you never
accomplish your goal goals the answer is
always action it's hope and then action
and when that doesn't work out more
action and when that doesn't work out
more action so a couple years ago I was
in New York and I was meeting with my
agents in one of them
said what am I trying to do what's
what's my vision what's my mission what
I'm trying to accomplish and I said I
wanted to spread the leaf I wanted to
spread hope and he jumped all over me
about the Hope like you want to spread
hope Hope's not enough you can't just do
hope and and I remember walking away
he's like what's he talking hope is so
important if you don't have hope how are
you going to believe in yourself to go
chase something down without hope you
got nothing right without hope and
belief you got nothing
where I realized the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people hope things will happen it's not
having hope in something it's hoping
that it's gonna happen and then they sit
on their bed sit on their couch sit at
home and do nothing
that kind of hope that's not a strategy
hope and belief is your first step it's
your first entry point in you have hope
that things will happen but then you
gotta get up and do something right and
so
figuring out that message when I was
talking to my agent didn't come to you
right away in the moment because at the
same time as much as I'm filled with
hope and belief in humanity and what we
can all do I'm work right I'm taking
action I'm making three to four videos
every day we haven't had a day in the
past five years where video hasn't gone
up every single day I don't know what
that consecutive streak is but it's long
it's big
I'm working my face off every day in the
achievement of my mission but I also
love hope and belief it's why I have
this channel so I have my other channels
is I want I want to be around people
who've done a lot more I want to learn
from the great so I'm going to learn
from people who know more than me and
when I see that it gives me hope that
it's possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it I can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus actually executing and
doing it are two very different things
right the difference Gap is going to be
the action
and so yes I want you to have hope I
think it's important but it's not the
only thing you got to make sure you turn
that hope and not just rely on a
strategy but you're doing the daily work
to chase down your dreams every time you
say I can't
you suck because you've quit because
you've given up it's not your fault that
you can't do it it's your work or your
school or your family or all the other
commitments that you have but not your
fault nope
nope
nope change your I can't to either I'm
going to or I choose not to that's how
you take back control of your decisions
and your life so I recently listened to
this Chinese song and I got obsessed
with it I got obsessed with it I was
playing it all day long and I just I
loved I don't know what they're saying I
don't know which I don't know what the
words mean I just loved I loved it I
loved it I go to bed and lyrics start
coming to me rap lyrics
in full sentences right the first one
comes in okay wake up I'm in bed I'm
lying in bed I'm trying to sleep you
know it's 11 o'clock trying to say
constant idea rap lyric come okay I
write it down again Raptors come write
it down more and more and more write it
down until three in the morning I
haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like I need to make a rap
and then what comes into my head is that
what you can make a rap
it's easy to get locked in into I can't
mode I can't do this I can't start that
I can't do a rap I didn't go to school
for that not that you go to school for
rap you know I didn't rap growing up I
don't have musical Talent right that's
not what people know me for that's how
people expect from me I can't rap
ah
that's where most people quit
but instead I decided I was gonna get up
at three something in the morning go to
my computer finish writing out my lyrics
and then I spent the day rapping and
that night finished the video sent it
off to uh Christina my Editor to put it
together and the next day we released my
rap video now maybe you love it maybe
you hate it it's gotten some decent
responses it was tons of fun to put
together and most importantly I taught
myself in all of these things these are
all great micro moments to teach
yourself that you're amazing
whenever you say I can't and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is taking something that you think that
you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because I
don't expect my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but I tried it
I did it I released it expect the second
beginning that's okay it's normal it's
part of the process but in those moments
of I can't and then turning them into
something that actually exists
is where your Genius will come
I look at my top 10 series and partly
why I have Kanye on my wall because the
first video that I made was on Kanye
first top 10 was on Kanye was five years
into my YouTube career
I did a response to my friend Mark
Draeger
from Phantom media and I said initially
I can't do this like I can't make a
video now on this I have all these other
commitments I have a full day ahead of
other stuff that I'm supposed to do and
said no
I did action I'm just gonna do it forget
it I'm gonna make it and I didn't expect
it to do well
luckily it actually did and then that
became this whole thing of making I
don't know how many top tens hundreds
maybe a thousand I don't know how many
top ten how many top times have I done I
have no idea
but it started off as this idea
trust your ideas
know that they're amazing
stop saying I can't to yourself this is
where you need to take control of your
head and your heart you have to make
decisions with your heart and then use
your head to figure out how to do it
you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something
new I'm making it I'm gonna make a rap
I'm gonna make a top 10 video I'm gonna
do anything outside my normal thing
right same for you anytime you're doing
something new it doesn't make sense
because it's new what is brand new
doesn't make sense you're creating
something new and so your head your
logical brain that's designed to keep
you safe doesn't understand it its job
is to to protect you and says don't do
that you can't do that
because one has ever been done and
because we have all these reasons why
it's not possible for you not just
anybody else for you you can't do it
because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says your heart
can create something new your heart
creates art your heart makes up a world
that hasn't existed before and so at the
very beginning of many projects you're
heading your heart are against each
other your heart's saying I want to make
this your heart's thinking you can't
make this and so you end up staying
stuck in limbo with all these ideas
never taking momentum because you're
you're ahead and your heart are fighting
you've got your foot on the gas and the
break at the same time never moving
knowing that you're capable of more and
so you make the big decisions in your
life with your heart and then you rally
your head to say okay we're doing this
I'm making the rap video I'm making the
top ten you're gonna do your crazy idea
and then your head says ooh okay they're
serious let's figure out how not to die
doing this right let's figure out how to
actually make it work
so you make the big decisions in life
with the heart and then you use your
head to figure out how to go out and
accomplish it having an infinite mindset
comes from you wanting people to win
more than you want them to win with you
you want people to win around you your
friends your family your team your
customers the people you interact with
you want them to win as people in their
life in their goals whatever they want
to accomplish you want them to win
more than you want them to win with you
if you can start to adopt that mindset
it really starts to shift how you see
your relationships how you see your
business how do you see the people on
your team and it allows so much more
positive energy to flow in the right
direction for everybody to accomplish
their goals so quick example
I made a video I made a bunch of videos
on Tony Robbins Tony Robbins is one of
the first people that well he was I
guess the first big person who kind of
recognized the work that I was doing and
he put the video I made on him on his
home page on YouTube and got a lot more
views and we made more videos than Tony
Robbins Tony then invites me to go to
his event we did a couple interviews
together he invites me to go and puts me
in you know the awesome seating right up
front and I got a lot of people coming
up to say hey Evan they recognize me I'm
also wearing the hoodie not that I'm a
celebrity but in that kind of world
people would recognize me and they said
you introduced me to Tony Robbins
that they found out about Tony Robbins
or Simon sinek or Tom bilyu or whoever
threw the content that I'm putting up
and I had a few people who said hey I I
found out about Tony Robbins from you
and I haven't actually gone back and
watched your videos in a while because
I've been so deep in Tony Robbins land
and now I'm here at this event and paid
thousands of dollars to be here learning
from Tony
and I don't watch your channel anymore
but thank you for introducing me to Tony
Robbins because that's what I watch now
I'm pumped
excited it's like that's amazing
thank you for telling me
now what I would I love for them to be
with me forever yes of course absolutely
but I'm more happy that you're off
winning if you watch this video and you
learn from Simon sinek and you've never
heard of him before you have and you
want to dive deeper and then you go and
you buy all his books and you subscribe
to him on YouTube and you dive deep into
his world and you don't come back and
watch another video of mine for another
12 months I'm I'm pumped for you I want
you to win as a human as an entrepreneur
more than I want you to subscribe to my
channel and keep watching videos here
it's just a fundamental shift in how you
see relationships I look at the people
on my team I want them all to win as
people more than win with me and I see
everybody that I'm working with as a
parallel path
you and I right now you're watching this
video we're on a parallel path this is a
parallel path that we're we're marching
on together and then at the end of this
video you're going to go off and go do
something else and hopefully productive
and empowering and impactful you're
gonna have a great day come on let's go
believe Nation but you're gonna go off
and do something else you're gonna
you're gonna step out the different
Carmichael path and go do something else
and maybe you come back on the path or
maybe you go way off and you and you
never come back but right now you're
watching this video we're on a parallel
path you and I together
I just want to maximize that time
together that while you're on a path
with me that you're going to become
better and that should be your goal with
the people you're around that we have
these parallel paths that we're running
together for a certain amount of time
and maybe that's 10 minutes in a
conversation maybe that's a year of
somebody working with you maybe that's
10 years maybe that's a life partner
that's forever right but you're on these
parallel paths your goal needs to be
while somebody's interacting with you in
person via email through your content
they're with you that they're a better
person because of that interaction with
you
if you can do that if you can just
change the way you see relationships to
do that to instead just think about
yourself first and think about them
first and helping them accomplish what
they need to accomplish even if it means
leaving you I've I've recommended people
to courses and programs that are not my
own I've kicked people off of my team
because
I was going to hold them back they
wanted to stay here but like you need to
go and do that thing this is too safe
and comfortable for you and I can't give
you the thing that you want
you have to leave and go do that thing
and push them towards it what you
believe about yourself is the only thing
that matters at the end of the day no
matter how much outside affirmations you
get or other people telling you that
you're amazing if you don't believe in
your heart that you are amazing it won't
none of that will last like you've ever
gone to an event or you ever made a
video or created something or you're
hanging out with a friend and they tell
you how amazing you are and that feels
good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades that stuff doesn't
last you don't have somebody being a
cheerleader for you every day showing up
in your bedroom saying hooray go do this
you're amazing right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never going to love your life
you're never going to love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
it's like for me it's this is why I
believe that lack of belief is the
world's number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we are very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives they're barely
hanging on most people are barely
hanging on
we're barely hanging on to what we're
doing we we can post all these great
things on Instagram or wherever and make
it look like we're enjoying our life but
most people are barely hanging on the
people who are judging you for your life
and telling you that you suck hate their
own lives they are barely hanging on so
how do we get through it well yes we can
be harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
um I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masking
and insecurity right it's like those
people who uh you've ever seen those
memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything now he's like doesn't care
you know just walking on a T-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masculine
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk her out and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if it came on you would have to you
would have to move right it doesn't mean
that you're up and like dancing through
the whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today
yeah it's but I demand excellence and
that that starts with music because I
don't have I don't want to spend a lot
of time trying to get into the right
state of mind I can command it whenever
I want just by putting on the right song
so be in tension with your music and the
lyrics being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rucking a walk
to Tim Hortons usually get a coffee
you know this costs two bucks two
something so if I only had now what's
the what's the best money I spend every
year well it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and I'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and I'm thinking about what I
want to accomplish today in the lives
that I want to serve and the people I
want to help and and what I'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brand lytics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
um if you like to meditate meditate I
mean it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe walks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters is how
you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation and somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things you don't have
to be an extrovert to sell you also
don't have to be a slime ball to sell
either all you need to sell is a vision
that you believe in and a passion to
make it come true and if you don't learn
to effectively sell that genius idea
that you have in here that can serve the
world will never come to fruition and
you'll never get the impact that you're
after so I'm here in LA and over the
past two days I've been on the podcast
for Jordan Belfort Wolf of Wall Street
and Jay Abraham who's the legendary
marketing Guru for Tony Robbins and
Damon John and a whole bunch of other
people and I'm on their podcast and I'm
telling them that they need to be on
YouTube that they need to get their
message out I want to see them more
heavily invested I want to see their
message reach the world and
five years ago
Evan five years ago would have been too
afraid to humbled to worried that I
might not be perfect that I wouldn't be
able to persuade them to do the thing
and so I wouldn't have tried
and I still have a bit of that in me
when when Jordan Belfort asked me how
good are you like how good at YouTube
are you and the answer that I gave was
within the thought leadership world if
you you want to help entrepreneurs I'm
I'm top three five in the world
even as I said it feels weird saying it
because the the Canadian or Carmichael
kind of humbleness is pumping in but
it's also true
because when you're talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get an
understanding when I'm talking to Jordan
Belfort and trying to give him an
understand of what I do and why my
message is so important for him I'm
trying to serve him I'm trying to help
him I want him to win
so The credibility is important backs it
up and me not strongly believing in
myself means that he won't believe in me
either and one of my favorite messages
from Jordan when I told him this at the
beginning of the podcast interview was
sales
is about a transfer of certainty of all
the things I've learned from Jordan
Belfort that is the number one thing
that still Rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something again not for
nefarious reasons not to screw somebody
over not just to get their money you
want to persuade them I'm here try to
persuade Jordan trying to persuade Jay
trying to persuade lots of other people
to take their message and put it up on
YouTube to spread it to the world it's
for them right I got frustrated with
Jordan halfway through the interview and
he said why are you frustrated because
he's making it a joke in some and having
fun and he loves having fun on the show
and and it's a more entertaining show
he's way more funny and entertaining
than I am I told him you're doing this
for the audience because people watch
the show I'm doing this for you like
we're here at a limited time and I want
you to win I want to get this out of my
head into here so you can go to action
on it right
so the ability to sell and persuade is
based off your ability to transfer
certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing when you fully believe in a thing
like this is right this is a thing that
has to happen in service in service for
your customer in service for your
audience you have to do this not for me
but because it's the best thing for you
when you fully believe it then you have
to go all in on it if you change how you
feel about something you change how you
act the problem is most of the time we
don't catch our feelings if you're
feeling negative angry frustrated
depressed it doesn't matter what the
thing is that you're trying to
accomplish you're not going to give it
your all and you're not going to get
results because of your negative
emotional state if you don't start
changing how you feel you're never going
to make progress on the goals that you
set for yourself so one of the things I
love doing whenever faced in a negative
situation is say it's the best it's the
best I'm wearing this hat says Fanta
because friend of the channel Mark
Drigger pointed out to me when I was
saying it's the best that I'm a reframer
I'm refreshed man I never heard of the
concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you
spin it you reframe it so that it's
positive so that it motivates you so
that's exciting so that it pushes you
forward instead of it being a negative
thing that is all encompassing and
depressing and brings you down and he
said well you're always positive because
you're just a reframer and it he has his
anagram and I'm a number six or
something I don't know he he can give
you more details you want to know what
number you are and what it means go
follow mark.jig on Instagram and ask him
but
think that's
summer how to do
it learn how to reframe you take
whatever negative situation that's in
front of you and say this is the best
right now this is the best where this
came from was I was on an airplane from
Vancouver to Los Angeles and that's a
five hour flight give or take and I have
to sit next to this really smelly dude
and there was no other option I had to
stay on the plane I had to make my
flight I had to speak at this event the
only other option was get off the plane
and it was really smelly I'm sure he
didn't want to be smelly I'm sure that
wasn't his you know intention or
ambition it just happened probably had
three stopovers you know I hadn't
showered in in however long and just
he's stuck and in my head I'm trying to
find Solutions there's no Solutions and
so I'm upset I'm complaining you know
the 15 seconds of back and forth this
sucks I can't believe it and then here's
what happens in my head I say this is
the best this negative thing that's in
front of me right now this is the best
this is my chance to show myself what
I'm made of right and so he's sitting
right here next to me I'll look over
and just breathe it in
breathe that in breathe in that smell
breathe it in
to show myself
that this is not the limit
that this one dude is not going to ruin
my day and I feel great now about myself
because self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things and I just did
something difficult and that's where
it's the best came from it was a it was
a quick trigger to myself to say this is
the best it's the best and now it's
become this thing that anytime I'm
facing a really negative situation that
feels overwhelming and possible just
want to complain find someone to blame
and say it's your fault no this is the
best this is my change to show myself
and the world what I am made of and so
you can flip it for yourself what is so
overwhelming so impossible so crazy that
is bringing you down you look at your
calendar you look at your list of emails
and it's just depressing great this is
the best if you believe like I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
if you believe that the thing that you
struggled with the most in life becomes
your calling for the rest of your life
the time that you struggled and suffered
the most as a human your your purpose
for the rest of your life is to help
other people who currently are who you
used to be then that thing that happened
that that massively negative thing the
most painful moment in your life
actually is the best
because it's going to allow you to serve
hundreds thousands maybe millions of
people through your purpose so that
negative things in front of you tell
yourself it's the best one of the things
that really helped me
was leaning into
the fact that I'm shy and introverted
and afraid to get in front of the camera
and afraid to get on stage and no need
to be famous that's led to actually a
lot of opportunities
[Laughter]
more I lean in on those things the more
things come to me I remember doing a
speech at Brandon burchard's growth
event and
I wasn't as myself I was more
professional I was more just given
advice great great advice people loved
it and then he invited me back to speak
at his uh private Mastermind and now
this these groups are paying 30 to 50
000 to be in that room uh so now there's
higher pressure you know like the first
one the ticket was gonna be 100 bucks
the ticket to this one is thirty
thousand dollars a fifty thousand
dollars like oh my gosh extra pressure
and
I just leaned in on it
I I walked up on stage and I I came
after Dean graziosi so Dean spoke and
then it was me and Dean was using the
Flipboard
uh you know this is like a paper beside
you and you're you're flipping one page
at a time and I'd never used a Flipboard
in in any of my presentations I've had
PowerPoint in the past or I normally
just get up and talk but I thought okay
I'm gonna try to use the Flipboard
and I didn't know how to use it I I
always felt like I was blocking somebody
uh so I'm hiding behind the Flipboard
trying to write it and it ended up being
really funny and um
Brendan took me aside after and he said
that was the best that was so much
better than you did at in Arizona at my
first event and Arizona was great but
like you need to lean in on your
goofiness you need to lean in on your
shyness you need to lean in on the
things that make you nervous if you're
if you're nervous say you're nervous if
you have anxiety say you have anxiety
um I I'd LED with something like that
it's like I'm I'm scared I'm an
introvert I'm shy and I've got my heart
beating like crazy right now standing up
here in front of all you guys that's how
it led my speech something like that
um and so leaning in on that has helped
has helped me it's a lot more real
yeah it's a lot more real so you don't
feel like you have to be fake you can
just lean in on the thing that makes
your heart go crazy like this lean in on
it if you were to make a video to say I
want to tell you my story
if I go back to the landscaping company
I want to tell you why I do what I do
and normally I hate making videos and
this makes me really anxious and nervous
and I'm scared to do this but
Landscaping is just so important
it's so important to me because and then
you tell the story with the mom wouldn't
you want to hire that person wouldn't
you want to pay more for that person
right so leaning in on your story on the
thing that you're worried that you're
going to get judged for is the way that
you're gonna win if you want to become a
millionaire or influence a million
people you need to learn to build trust
this is where you can really win as an
entrepreneur because people have a
really hard time trusting big companies
to do the right thing so this is where
you win
you win by not trying to be exactly like
the big companies you win by showing
that you actually care and will do the
right thing by the customer so bringing
it to a YouTube world as an example I
think everybody should be responding to
all comments one of the things that I
believe in is every comment we try to
get a response to every comment gets a
response every comment gets a response
and at the beginning when you're doing a
YouTube channel it's easy my first video
on YouTube it took me a year to get
three comments I made a video within one
year there were only three comments on
that video the first comment was my mom
thank you Mom the second comment was my
older sister thank you Alexandra and the
third comment was from some random dude
a new somebody discovered my channel
right one year three comments those are
pretty easy to respond to right it's
super easy in the early days when you're
not getting comrades if you're getting a
comment a day a comment a week couple
comments a day it's easy to respond to
what happens when people scale is they
stop responding to comments because they
don't know how to scale the business
because at the beginning they're doing
everything themselves and it doesn't
take up a lot of time but as you start
getting more comments it starts to take
up more time
I get hundreds of comments every day on
my on my YouTube channel I
can't respond to every single comment
personally myself
if I could I could if I did it then I
wouldn't do anything else I'm gonna be
making this video because I was spending
all my time responding to people's
comments right that's the process but
just like any other business when you
start a business you're doing everything
yourself if you start selling flowers on
the street you're doing everything right
you got to find the flowers you got to
sell the flowers you got to distribute
the flowers you're doing everything
as you grow and as you get a flower
store then you bring on a team right and
you have people who are selling flowers
for you and open this door for you
including the store for you you're still
doing work right you're doing more
important work you can't do all of the
tasks in the business at all times if
you're always doing everything you're
never going to scale
and so I believe that bigger YouTube
channels should hire a team to respond
to comments I have an awesome guy my
team named velco so you'll see
responding to a lot of comments and
he'll save the comments that I need to
see so if there's feedback or
suggestions or improvements I want to
see them if this criticism I want to see
it if it's just saying thank you Evan
for the video amazing I feel the love I
don't need to see all of those comments
that come in right I'll I'll sort
through some of them respond to some of
them but that's not gonna be the best
use of my time every day because then
I'm not making videos and so make that
equivalent for yourself
at the beginning it's easy to show hard
easier to show care because you don't
have that many customers because maybe
you only have one customer and so you
can show them the love but as you scale
and grow how can you continue to do that
whether it's you doing that most
important element yourself because
that's the thing that drives it or you
have people on your team that really
show that love and support because you
want to make sure the customer feels
respected and appreciated it's really
easy to build trust in a one-on-one
situation it's harder as you build and
scale your clients and so you need to
build and skill your culture alongside
you look at the people who've made big
money they've been they've been chasing
something that they love doing
because otherwise you won't put it in a
fork if you're just chasing an
opportunity you're probably not going to
make it if you don't love it enough
the people who love it will crush you
like if salsa dancing was the hot trend
for 2020 you could say great I'm going
to make tons of money salsa dancing
being a being an instructor and then
I'll do that for three years and then
retire and go travel the world and do
what I love you'll never make the money
salsa dancing because Alex is going to
destroy you
sorry yeah because he loves it right
because you'll you'll be a a wannabe and
you'll never put in enough work to
actually get great at the thing like if
you're if you're going to work with
somebody who's going to be in your in
your production
and they're just they just want to make
it as an actor because they think it's a
path to make tons of money because Brad
Pitt makes 40 million dollars a movie or
whatever it is
but they don't actually care about being
a good actor
they're not going to get into your show
like you're going to spot that out and
say no I need people who actually care
about the craft everything in your life
changes when you learn to tie yourself
your self-worth to to your effort
instead of the results most people tie
their software to the results to winning
you only feel good about yourself when
you win if that's how you think then
you're screwed because that person only
takes on projects that you know you have
a pretty high chance of winning at and
therefore you play small for Life the
key is to tie yourself Worth to the
effort to trying and if you do that well
you'll win Beyond Your Wildest
imaginations so let's use me as an
example look at this video right here
this video
two minutes before getting on to making
I'm nervous I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why I've done 6 000 of these videos
do I not love it anymore nope that's not
it I love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through
I put this pressure on myself to say
this video right now has to be the best
video that I've ever made that's my
intention going in to every time I'm
filming most days I don't accomplish it
when you're trying something new and
scary and bigger and Bolder most the
time you won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie myself worth my respect to the
effort I'm trying and every now and then
you'll make a bit of a breakthrough you
get a bit of a win
and then those accumulate and then you
get another one and another win and
another win and so the answer isn't have
a big goal and then find a reason why
you can't do it the answer isn't dream
big and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is the push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
buildings to get up and try again and
try again and try again and pat yourself
on the back for the effort you're
putting in not just when you're winning
so how do you do it I'm going to give
you a three-step process that I think
will help step number one is what I call
the pillow test this is my actual pillow
that when I'm in Toronto I sleep on
every single night and the pillow test
is make yourself proud before you hit
your head on the pillow right before you
go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not did I get the results I
was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in
that's the test that's the test for
tonight that's your test for tomorrow
night and the night after that and the
night after that and the night after
that and the more that you get a yes to
say yeah
heck yeah
heck yeah I'm proud of my effort you do
that you watch your business explode
step number two is expect to suck at the
start anytime you're trying something
new expect to suck don't expect to just
try something new and it's amazing this
is where a lot of people fall down
you've had some success you're at a
certain level you're going to try
something new before you go up you're
probably going to go down
that's part of the experimentation
process it doesn't mean you suck as a
human it just means that you don't have
the skill sets the talents yet you're
trying something new
I haven't brought props in on my videos
before that was a new test I expect it
to suck maybe on an off chance it works
amazing I learned from it but when
you're trying something it's brand new
you don't have the confidence in it yet
you're still figuring out the path
expect to suck when you put so much of
your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make a video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it it
would eventually be awesome you'd
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos come back go back to my
main Channel go back to the beginning
see where I started I've kept them all
up so you can see the journey the
progress of how much I sucked at the
very beginning it took me 350 videos
until I wasn't embarrassed by my content
I was I was so embarrassed I couldn't
watch it back 350 videos but I kept
going
the problem is people are quitting on
things too soon you quit on something
too soon because you're not getting
immediate results expect to suck it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human it
just means you don't have the skills yet
I had to get the skills by practicing
and number three is ask yourself what
would the most bold version of you do I
got this question was talking to my
video guy Danny who came to me with a
really important personal problem in his
life at the time and I said what would
the most bold version of you do it just
came out man I love that
and anytime he doesn't know what to do
he asks himself that question what would
the most bold version of me do it's a
great question because it allows you to
push through a lot of your fears a lot
of your insecurities to force yourself
to be bold and you want to be bold
you're meant to be bold
you're meant to create amazing wonderful
things you want that big vision of yours
to come true you are bold you are
courageous
but we don't live in that land very
often and so if you ask that question
what would the most bold version of you
do today what it does is wash away a lot
of those fears and insecurities and
gives you the answer that you're
actually looking for
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the fastest way to achieve your
goals is to model the people who've
already achieved the same goals that you
have model success success excludes the
famous expression and it's true people
have already figured out the thing that
you are struggling to figure out